e
e e
morning everybody it being around
10:04 uh we'll start uh the public
hearings in transportation but before we
do that could we please stand and for
the Pledge of
Allegiance Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all well good morning everyone just to
kind of give everyone a kind of a status
representative uh chairman Walsh will
not be here this morning so I'll be
running the hearing so be he'll be here
after lunch so this should be a fun time
this
morning uh so with that let's start off
with our first Bild um HB 249 allowing
bicycles to treat stop signs as yield
signs and stop lights as stop signs in
the chair we like to recognize
representative uh Miller who uh who is
the Prime sponsor of the bill welcome
sir thank you very much Mr chairman and
good morning uh thank you all for the
opportunity to introduce uh HB 249 here
today
uh hb2 249 is an excellent opportunity
uh for uh represent can you just
introduce yourself I'm sorry name and
who you represent thank you thank you
yeah sorry about that uh Seth
representative Seth Miller uh straford
21 representing do
um h249 gives us an excellent
opportunity to address uh two major
traffic challenges is uh safety and
traffic flow on the streets of New
Hampshire and best of all it lets us do
it for free um we can improve both of
those things at no cost to the Grand
estate um the idea of what's known as a
safety stop uh first was legislated in
1982 uh as in Idaho it was known as
Idaho stop as a result of that and it
allows for uh bicyclists to treat a stop
sign as a yield sign uh in Idaho they
saw a 14.5% drop in injuries as a result
of enacting this law uh 40 years ago and
the numbers have stayed low since um
more recently Delaware introduced uh
what they call the Delaware yield
worried I didn't come up with a cool New
Hampshire related acronym or nickname
for this but we'll work on that maybe as
an amendment um Delaware has the
Delaware yield uh in 2017 uh research
from the nhsa uh or data from the nhsa
and other resources shows that they had
a 23% drop in accidents at stop sign
intersections over the 30 months
following that compared to the 30 months
prior there there is real data across
multiple states that have done this that
shows it is massively safer for
cyclists um I will point out that most
importantly uh two things one it is
still optional cyclists who want to stop
or need to stop or should stop will stop
or at least should um and they you still
must yield uh this is not that you just
get a green light at any stop sign this
is it is a yield sign you are still
expected to pay attention to the laws of
the road and yield to Crossing traffic
where appropriate the the main focus
here is keeping cyclists moving even at
very low speeds and for some of you who
may not have ridden a bike in a while
but may you know I'd like to think we
all did at some point at least as a kid
um that first few seconds getting off
the ground when you pick your foot up
and you start moving forward you're
wobbly you're moving at one or 2 miles
an hour that wobble there uh it's a
slower portion of the ride you're much
less safe you're much less in control
once you get moving you get a couple
miles per hour under you you're you're
rolling that's where you have the
balance that's where you have control of
your bicycle and so what this bill does
is by making it a yield sign you
maintain that speed you don't
necessarily have to drop below the 3 to
five miles an hour and get into that
wobble State on your bike unless of
course cross traffic or other reasons
that you need to actually stop while
you're yielding um the other thing that
it does is helps traffic flow and it's
important to note that because the
cyclist is not coming to a Full Stop um
they they move through the intersection
more quickly again a a car uh anything
motorized 0o to 5 miles hour is pretty
easy you tap the pedal you move uh a
cyclist it's especially if you're on a
heavier bike um with Cargo in it or
things like that you're self-powered you
have to get that moving up to the 3 to 5
m an hour to get things moving so the
car behind you can roll to the stop sign
perform its stop and then move forward
again we by moving the bicycle go
through that intersection more quickly
the cars behind it can also flow more
quickly so it's a smoother flow of
traffic for vehicles as well um and one
other thing I will point out I know we
did have a hearing about Lane filtering
and motorcycles recently and we had so
we have had some discussion about this
type of thing uh in the past couple
weeks this is has substantially
differences from the lane filtering
approach most notably uh cyclists are
not weaving between the cars to get up
to the front of traffic they are still
within their step you know sort of their
cycle of how things flow it's just a
matter of when they get there they can
move through the intersection more
quickly and safely for everybody um with
that uh I will note that I think
everybody has received emails at least
two or three times with the nhsa uh uh
research data on it if you haven't I
will for your copy I chose not to print
30 copies of it because I didn't think
we need them but if anyone wants a hard
copy let me know um and with that I
would be happy to take any questions
from
you thank you very much any questions
from the committee representative
Crawford thank you Mr thank you Mr chair
uh thank you representative Miller for
taking the question the only thing I see
that's different in here um
from regular moving traffic is on line
21 it says a leftand turn onto a one-way
High way may be made on on a red light
after stopping and yielding to other
traffic could you explain why you you
put that in
there um thank you yeah I should
probably have a copy of this in front of
me to make sure I get it right but um I
believe that's from the stop uh is that
is that a red light yeah so there I
should note there's two halves of the uh
the Idaho stop is considered a stop
light soon a stop sign situation there's
also the uh treating a red light as a
stop sign um that goes back to the idea
that again when yielding appropriately a
bicycle often is not doesn't have the
weight or magnetic signature to trigger
a a lane detection signal so if you're
at a left turn lane often times those
have the little wires in the ground or I
know New Hampshire we use the cameras
now for a lot of those things but if you
don't trigger that the idea is you can
sit and wait and wait and wait and you
could theoretically be stuck there
forever until a car comes up behind you
to help uh S turn that signal for you
um so again this allows for when safe to
be able to make that left turn onto the
road I believe you want to follow
up follow
up so I do recall a bill similar to that
for motorcyclist and I believe do U
testified that a red light the longest
you're ever going to sit at a red light
is 120 seconds is that still
correct no they
did did do I mean I guess I'd ask do I
know do is going to be speaking later
we're can have them clarify that ask
that question then thank you you get a
hint of what you're going to get
congratulations representative
pataro thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question are you a
cyclist yes okay follow up
followup um I imagine within the cycling
Community there are different like
levels of skill in one sense you have
hobbyists and another sense you have the
people with the
um the the gear and and the the the
shoes that like plug into the pedals yep
right
um would you say that PE bicyclists at
all levels um are in favor of of this
bill no like anything else I think
there's a variety of opinions on the
bill and where you know the law should
be um again I will remind you that as I
mentioned in my testimony there is no
requirement that a cyclist roll through
a stop sign when if this is enacted you
still can stop um you are encouraged to
act and behave in a way that is
considered safe both for you and the
other traffic around you and so for if
you are comfortable stopping a full stop
there that is complet okay uh thank you
uh Mr chair can I ask one more question
all up okay um the language added in
this bill talks about not just bicycles
but human powerered vehicles and
electric bicycles um could you elaborate
on what what those mean what those are
uh under New Hampshire law electric
bicycle is a specific classification of
bicycle um and is treated almost
universally the same as a manual powered
bicycle um and so that inclusion here is
to make sure that it's clear that it
applies to both of those categories and
so um there's a whole section of the RSA
about electric bikes and notes that they
are basically bikes um human powered
vehicles could be
other things that are not the
traditional two wheels with a frame in
between a trike um that is wheel
powerered or electric uh but is more
like a bicycle than anything else
there's those cool like ski things that
you sort of push your pedals on that
moves but it's sort of thing it's those
types of vehicles um and again that that
is that was included based on best
practices from other states that have
done similar things to make sure we are
recognizing the types of vehicles that
we would expect to be able to take
advantage of this law excellent answer
thank you very much y representative
Hill thank you Mr chairman um like any
of these uh changes uh my concern
is not knowing what when I when I come
to an intersection and traffic is
stopped on either side I don't know I
need to know what those people are going
to do here it sounds like I would not
know what that bicyclist is going to do
whether because it's voluntary whether
they are going to continue on and and
say that they are U not yielding they're
going through the stop sign or whether
they are stopping
so how can you speak to the uncertainty
of the person that is coming to that
intersection and and seeing bicyclists
approaching and not knowing what what
the bicyclist plans to do sure um
I am not in the brain of all those
bicyclists so I will speak to it from
you know or of all the drivers but my my
understanding my expectation would be
that when I am approaching an
intersection and a a cyclist is
approaching from the other side and
let's assume we both have stop signs or
it's a four-way stop something of that
nature um the cyclists would still
respect the fact that they have to yield
if there is cross traffic and would
otherwise apply the sort of rules of who
has right of way when multiple Vehicles
approach a stop at the same time so if I
am to your right on a bicycle and you
are coming up and we both get there at
the same time I would have right of way
whether I came to a full stop or treated
that stop sign as a yield because that
is what the rules of the road say if you
are to my right and I we are coming up
you have the right of way and as
specified in the law I am obligated to
yield to you as we approach at the same
time and that sucks for me because I
lose my momentum and have to stop and go
through you know the wobble phase and
all those other things again but I would
expect that that is how the law is
written that is how it continues to be
written with this uh Amendment or this
alteration of the law and that's how it
would be adhered
to representative gon thank you Mr chair
uh thank you representative Miller
taking the question so you I've reviewed
a lot of laws similar to this in the
motorcycle world the left turn on red
the lane filtering Etc and all those
laws specifically state State somewhere
that the operator that is doing
something non-standard is liable for
damages for their own safety and and
establishes that this this new code of
law does not change the laws of right
away I don't see anything with regards
to liability in this and that concerns
me do you know if that's covered under
another code of law or what your answer
to that is Sir uh thank you for the
question I do not know if that's covered
specifically elsewhere um on the laws uh
I mean I I don't believe that there is
specific uh mention of who has liability
when a cyclist is on the road generally
um other than they are obligated to
respect the laws of the road and so um
I'm going to say terrible thing I would
assume terrible mistake to make that uh
th if this is the law and the uh this it
is I would say this doesn't this makes
it so it's non-standard in that bikes
are treated differently than Motor
Vehicles
but it is standard in that it is the law
and so a cyclist who does not yield when
they should is still liable just as if
they ran a stop sign today and should
have
yielded is that
fair and I will offer if you if we
discover that it needs more in an
amendment that says that adds that line
to it would make you feel more
comfortable I'd be happy to entertain
that we can talk about that in a bit
representative
emble uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you representative Miller uh so I'm glad
you mentioned the lane filtering bill
that we recently discussed and if I
remember correctly uh it was
overwhelmingly itl in this committee
because it was creating a special class
of vehicle with their own laws and we
felt that people in general were not
used to a a special class of vehicles
with special laws that they could um do
that nobody else could do and so the
committee voted itl on it um so how is
this bill not creating a special class
of vehicles that get to operate by their
own laws that everybody else has not
been trained in uh as to how they're
going to
operate uh thank you for the question I
can't speak to I I agree that we all
ited uh we voted overwhelming itl the
lane filtering uh Bill I'm not sure the
reasoning all of us chose so I'm but uh
taking to to your point of different
types of rules for different types of
vehicles um there are different rules
for different types of vehicles we all
we all agree on many of them and it
behaves similarly but um how cyclists
have to behave in a lane and where
they're allowed to ride and things like
that are different than Motor Vehicles
so there there are already differences
in how motor vehicles and cyclists um um
are treated on the roads and how they're
expected to behave in certain scenarios
uh so I I understand the concern that oh
gosh I didn't know that bike was going
to only was going to roll through that
stop sign uh with the exception of the
scenario where you are a vehicle behind
that bicycle and you get to the stop
sign faster my expectation is you would
never experience that because otherwise
you are cross traffic and the bicyclist
is still going to yield to you so yes
there's a situation where they are
operating differently that is on purpose
because there's value in having giving
them the ability to operate differently
both for safety and for traffic flow and
the people who will notice it the only
notice they should have is the advantage
they get of moving through traffic more
quickly thank you any other questions
from the committee not seeing any thank
you sir thank you very much chair I'd
like to recognize Michael Frank who's
representing himself who supports the
bill who's asking for two to three
minutes welcome sir to
Transportation good
morning uh my name is Michael Frank I
live in spafford New
Hampshire I'm an avid long-term cyclist
I teach cycling safety as a league
cycling instructor
and I'm here to support hille
249 my home is 8 to 10 miles from the
retail centers of keen New Hampshire and
Brattleboro Vermont I commute regularly
by bicycle into these centers for
shopping and errands typically riding a
cargo bike which is designed to uh carry
large loads large heavy
loads it's not uncommon for my neighbors
to see me climbing Chesterfield Hill
with two three weeks of groceries on the
back of that
bicycle I only tell you this to showcase
the how this bill
can benefit me personally and my
safety when I bring my heavily loaded
bicycle to a full stop at a stop sign it
takes a great deal of effort to get that
bike rolling again and up to speed at
leaves me in the intersection longer and
it exposes me to Cross traffic
as well as the traffic who's coming up
behind
me if on the other hand I'm allowed to
slow as I approach the intersection
yield to any on any cross traffic and
then maintain my momentum I'm through
the intersection quicker and have less
exposure because I'm fully integrated
with the environment as I'm writing I
have an acute awareness of traffic
around me I have an unobstructed view of
what's surrounding me I have I can hear
vehicles coming from all quadrants and
indeed there are sometimes that I can
smell a vehicle a car or a truck coming
towards
me so I'm exquisitly aware of the
dangers that are approaching me from any
of those uh angles in an intersection so
as I approach that intersection if it's
unsafe for me to proceed through I'm
going to slow and
stop just as a motorist treats a yield
sign
by processing the information of whether
to slow and proceed through or stop for
the any oncoming traffic I'm able to do
that at an intersection controlled by a
red
octagon now this bill also calls for
allowance of the cyclist to treat a stop
light as a stop sign and I'd like to
speak to my personal experience with
that I frequently find myself at the
stop
line waiting for a red light as I'm in
the right hand
lane getting ready to proceed straight
through that intersection whenever the
light turns green for years I've had to
endure the Wrath of the motorist behind
me who wants to make a right-and turn on
a red light but I'm waiting there
waiting for that light to turn green as
he and I
stare at an empty
intersection if I have the ability to
pull up to the stoplight make sure that
there's no traffic coming and then
proceed through that allows me to get
through the intersection the traffic
behind me to make their right unre
privilege exercise that privilege if the
traffic behind me is going to follow me
straight through that that intersection
it allows me to get up to speed get some
space between the tra the vehicle behind
me and through the intersection and that
allows that driver the opportunity to
time his move to the left to get around
me these are all things that make my
life as a cyclist much more safer and
improves site vehicle flow traffic
flow I can Echo the prior testimony of
improved safety I can site the various
studies showing no negative impact on
the motoring public and I can point out
that
izing a common practice has in other
states caused an increase in cycling for
health and
Recreation but in my reading I can't
find any evidence that this law would
cause any expense to the state for these
reasons I respectfully ask you support
this legislation I thank you for your
time and consideration and I would
invite you to come down and ride around
spafford Lake with me
anytime any questions from the committee
representative St Clair thank you Mr
chair and thank you are you aware of any
bicyclists yourself included but
probably not you that have uh received a
ticket for um treating a red light as a
stop sign or coasting through a stop
sign or a traffic light on a bicy I can
speak to my my personal experience I
have not received a ticket I have uh had
an a discussion with an officer in
another
State um and I've had one state police
officer flash his lights at me just to
indicate that uh he knew that I'd roll
through the stop sign
okay thank you any other questions from
the committee not seeing any thank you
sir thank you chair i' like to recognize
Tim blagden who supports the bill asking
for two
minutes welcome Tim the
transportation thank you very very much
um I was the head of the bike walk
Alliance of New Hampshire from 2013 to
2016 I support the bill um this bill
reflects how um many people ride today
um we're all out um to keep ourselves
safe but um starting and stopping on a
bicycle takes effort and so if we can
approach a stop sign slow look around
and if it and if it's safe to do so
proceed that saves energy and saves time
and as previous people have testified it
also gets the the bicycle through the
intersection faster which is safer for
all of us um both on bikes and on cars
and similarly at a stop sign you if this
law were passed this the cyclist would
have to come to a complete stop at a red
light but if the intersection is empty
um of cross traffic it would be safe for
the it would be permissible for the
cyclist to then go through that uh empty
intersection where the red light is
there and uh we know that um signal
equipment is non-responsive in most
cases to bicyclists um motorcyclists
have the same uh reaction from the
equipment from time to time they put big
metal uh plugs on on the bottom of their
motorcycle so that they can trigger um
stop lights uh and occasionally at
certain intersections um cycling groups
have have uh stencl where to position a
bicycle so that the street light will
react to them but in the vast majority
of intersections street lights are
non-functioning to bicycles so this
allows a cyclist when it's safe to do so
to proceed through an intersection it's
it's good legislation it's what um I I
urge you all to support it happy to take
any
questions thank you any questions from
the
committee representative Fox thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question can you imagine in any scenario
a a bicyclist blowing through a busy
intersection just because
they of this law can I because of this
law no um Can can I
imag drivers of cars and and drivers of
bicycles all come from the same gene
pool there are some crazy folks out
there but um you know it is all us so if
you wouldn't do it and I wouldn't do it
no one should do
it representative s Clair thank you Mr
chair thank you I'll ask you the same
question are you aware of anybody in the
state of New Hampshire that's received a
ticket on a bicycle for treating a stop
sign as a yield sign or a traffic uh red
light I am not I think that would be um
better put to the office of Highway
Safety or the state police um
I can tell you that I know what the law
is and I don't look forward to Breaking
the Law so it the law as as written
today you do have to come to a full stop
and if you if you don't you're you're
breaking the law so you're looking in
both directions and making sure that
it's really empty and there's no cop
there it's a disincentive to get on a
bike and uh and this proposed law um
serves as an incentive it makes it
easier to do a journey on a bike through
intersections that either have stop
signs or lights and whether or not you
ride a bicycle you want as many people
as possible riding bikes because the
number of parking spaces we have in our
downtowns is limited if we want more
economic business to happen in those
areas and we all
do you can put 20 bikes in the same
space as a single parking spot so the
more people we can get to bike to those
destinations for that lunch or for that
errand the better we all are they're not
going to be taking the spot you and I
want when we're driving a car because
they're riding a bike and we're going to
get there first for the same reason
so we should love those folks for riding
a bike because the spots empty the
table's going to be empty if you and I
are having lunch together and they're
still going to get there and support
those businesses so I for there's a lot
of reasons I want to see more people
riding
bikes thank you any other questions from
the committee represent the pill thank
you Mr chairman um I should have asked
earlier uh to the prime sponsor is there
um is there any age limit on
this are are I five year olds able to
make that same um
uh process of D of using it as a yield
sign as a as a 35 year old so um
I have a 35-year-old son I have
5-year-old grandchildren and and um as a
as a parent I'm not dodging the question
the law does not have any age in in it
okay but as a parent um of a minor you
are responsible for their actions um I
do everything I can to make cycling
safer um and and more available to
people of all ages so I work for two org
or volunteer at two organizations that
have given bicycles to 13 elementary
schools and they're teaching
kindergarteners and first graders how to
ride bikes so it's not a theoretical
question that these kids who are five
six and seven are going to know how to
ride a bike but we do it because we're
building rail trails and think that
parents are going to take those kids out
for more practice on rail trails and
learn how to stop start and navigate on
a bike in a safe place before they
tackle any Street
so do I would I encourage somebody to
turn a 5-year-old loose on the streets
no would I expect to see someone who is
12 or above riding a bicycle on a street
I
would and I would expect them to follow
the
laws any other questions from the
committee representative pauo thank you
very very much and thank you for taking
my question I imagine the next years and
decades
New Hampshire might have specific areas
of urbanization and development and so
forth and with that comes bike Lanes do
you have any thoughts on how this bill
would intertwine with um bike lanes and
cities um if you look at
Transportation
um guide books isn't the wrong
standardization books and we have dot
here we have other people from cycling
organizations here so
um there are um there is infrastructure
techniques where if you have a bike lane
that comes up to an intersection and
then and it's heavily biked in a in a
place they can do a bike box at the
front of the intersection to allow the
bikes to move up and then get the jump
at the beginning of the intersection I
don't believe that the state of New
Hampshire has any of those here um yet
but there are ways to handle smoothly
more bicycling if if that's what you're
asking but honestly we are a long way
away from having that problem we would
that's a problem I would love to have um
so we need to make biking safer uh in in
many places first I appreciate it very
much thank you any other questions from
the committee not seeing any thank you
very
much just to let the members of the
committee know we do have the dot here
as one of the speakers so um
you know if you have some specific
questions there they'll be up here
shortly uh next chair I like to
recognize Paula Bard representing
herself asking for three minutes who
supports the bill and also has written
testimony if uh you have that give it to
the clerk we'd appreciate it welcome yep
thank you my name is Paula Bard I live
in Goffstown I'm here to speak in favor
of hb2 49 if passed it would allow
bicyclists to treat stop signs as yield
and stop lights as stop signs I've been
an avid bicyclist most of my life I
appreciate and value using a bicycle for
transportation Recreation and fitness um
as a transportational cyclist I commuted
to work by bike for many years I'm also
a certified bike safety instructor I
have my certification through the
national level League of American
bicyclist credential um they have a
smart cycling program uh and I've been
involved in teaching those curriculums
for over 15 years in my role as a bike
safety instructor I have been hired in
the past by organizations such as
Harvard University and Cambridge Mass
Dartmouth College in Handover New
Hampshire L University um and I've also
hosted many presentations on safe
cycling bike commuting ebikes bike
friendly driving which is a class that
educates Motor Vehicle drivers on safe
behaviors and laws when sharing roadways
with
bicyclists um in the past I've also
served on the New Hampshire Traffic
Safety commission and on several other
advocacy organizations serving as the
voice for bicyclists and pedestrian
rights responsibilities and safety
issues I'm in favor of HB 249 because it
increases bicycle safety and it allows
them to move through intersections and
away from congested traffic more quickly
for many decades now our traffic Studies
have consistently shown that
intersections are one of the most
dangerous locations for bicyclists they
are considered uh highrisk areas okay
the studies on locations that have
implemented the stop on yield uh this
law have indicated the increase in
bicyclist safety and I'd like to quote
from the Nitsa National Highway trans
ation safety administration's 2023 fact
sheet on this behavior and this is from
Nitsa based upon the current research
and data available these laws showed
added safety benefits for bicyclists
happy to take any uh questions if there
are any and thank you for the
opportunity to speak in favor of this
bill any questions from the committee
representative St Clair
thank you Mr chair yes and thank you and
yes my question is the same are you
aware of anybody in the state of New
Hampshire excuse me who has received the
traffic ticket for yes I I have a couple
of friends over the year people I know I
should say I have it's rare but I have
heard of instances and I know people
that have been cited by Lo local law
enforcement for infringements you know
and um I'm sure the issue is that um
primarily
a cyclist blowing through a traffic uh
uh intersection they're primarily
endangering themselves certainly not in
all cases but that is you know they're
mostly a danger to themselves but I do
know people that have been uh cited for
those types of
infractions thank you any other
questions from the committee not seeing
any thank you I'm so sorry
representative Peto thank you real quick
um uh I'm sorry I missed it uh could you
spell your last name b e d a r
d um followup follow up um you you seem
very professional on this subject do you
currently work for a bicycling
organization where we could reach out to
you or um you can certainly reach out to
me I'd be happy to provide contact
information I'm here speaking um on my
own I sort of semi-retired recently from
all the ad advocacy work that I have
been doing but I've been passionate
about safety issues for bicyclists and
pedestrians for decades um and I I don't
think I'll ever fully quit uh doing
advocacy um we live in such a car
Centric society that there needs to be
push back for people who want to bike
and walk in our communities and do it
safely thank you any other questions
from the committee not seeing any thank
you so much and if we can have the
written test Tony that'll be great and
give it to the
clerk chair El recognize representative
Reed who has want two minutes who
supports the bill welcome thank you Mr
chair and honorable members I wasn't
planning on testifying for the record my
name is Ellen Reed I represent
Rockingham 10 new Mark and newfields and
having to sit through the end waiting
for my bill I just thought I'd give an
assist to my two- wielded Brethren and
sister uh who are supporting this bill
and the reason I want because I have
come to talk to you about a different
bill which I won't try to conflate that
has to do with the behavior of two-
wheeled vehicles on the road um and I
find the same logical fallacy consisting
consistent through these different
hearings and that that fallacy is that
um this would somehow make the people
who are already engaging in illegal
Behavior do that illegal Behavior more
illegally and that's just not true if
people are running through red lights
now they're going to continue in the
future if they're engaged in Drag Racing
future so I don't I just want to caution
the committee before they engage in
debate that has to do with that logical
fallacy and I would like to also remind
the committee that people on two wheels
whether they be um powered or not
powered are doing a service to society
and so that kind of you want to
encourage that behavior especially with
bicycles um because they are helping
with traffic they are helping with theem
missions they are helping with um all
the things that we want people to to
help out with and so to incentivize that
would be to um help them transport
themselves in a safe way and having said
that I'd like to say that I ride a
bicycle every day I don't I have a a
body built by motorcycles so um I don't
think that there would be questions but
I've never heard of someone being
uh ticketed okay but again I'm not a
bicyclist I'm a vom vom thank you any
questions from the committee not seeing
any thank
you here like now like to recognize
Jonathan Vale representing himself who
so supports the bill who's asking for
five minutes if we could make it like
two to three we appreciate it uh yes sir
thank you for having me uh first time
here that's why I put five minutes I
didn't know what that would be so we'll
make it real quick I think uh people
have addressed the major points that I
came here to make so I just want to add
that uh my name is Jonathan Bale I'm
from nsha where I'm involved with the
gate City Bike Co-op uh the
Nash uh strong towns group and I'm also
a member of the bike walk Alliance of
New Hampshire uh I'm also a longtime
bike commuter uh recreational cyclist uh
and I commute year round uh plus or
minus snow to uh where I work in marac
um and on that drive I do go
through mostly some uh red lights uh
some of them uh as you say where I'm
taking blocking cars from getting
through uh in terms of waiting for the
red light when there's no other traffic
it would be beneficial to everybody to
go through safely uh and then allow the
cars to go through quicker when the
light changes uh I've also been a victim
of uh the dead Reds where you come up to
a red light and it doesn't change and
then you have to make the decision to go
through
anyway um to uh the question of have I
been ticketed I have not I've witnessed
um uh some kid getting pulled over for
doing something dumb I don't know if he
got ticketed either but um I don't know
if anybody who actually got ticketed in
the state of New Hampshire um I think uh
that's pretty much the points that I
came here to make uh in addition to the
ones that were there I'm happy to answer
any questions and appreciate your time
thank you any questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you sir
okay I like to recognize Bill Lambert
and Jerry
Bard who uh from the and New Hampshire
dot who do not have any position in the
bill asking for five to 10 sir if you
can make it a little bit shorter we'll
put behind appreciate it thank
you thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee for the record uh my name
is Bill Lambert I'm the highway safety
active Transportation administrator for
the Department of Transportation I have
with me today my colleague Jerry Bard
who's our active Transportation
administrator we pretty much represent
the the the scope or the span of bicycle
experience I have a bike in the garage I
tend to take it on vacation and ride
some early morning rides along very
rural roads Jerry commutes to work all
year round on his bicycle um so we
represent that gamut so representative
Crawford had asked about cycle length uh
so traffic signal cycle length is
usually going to be the maximum of 120
seconds so if you're on the main road
the major road you're likely to return
to that green light at no more than 120
seconds but if you're left turning off
the main road or entering from a minor
Road uh and the detection is not picking
you up you could be there indefinitely
just because you're not going to get
picked up so the cycle length maximum is
120 seconds but that only means that the
main road is going to rest red if
there's no traffic on the road it's
going to come back to that main rest
green it's going to come back to that
green light but the the side roads and
the left turns off the main road uh have
to be detected and if that detection is
not functioning or if it doesn't pick up
the vehicle it could be a while and I
think representative Miller mentioned
the um the newer signals have cameras we
do have video detection on some of the
the newer ones um but 450 or so signals
it's a long time before we have full
coverage of that uh around the state um
I'm here mostly to answer questions
those are the two that I caught from the
earlier testimony but I'd be happy to
answer any other questions thank you sir
any questions from the committee
representative J gason thank you Mr
chair thank you sir so uh one of my
questions was that there's no liability
um written into this law and based on
your expertise um should I be worried
about that or is that liability written
into other laws and what I mean by that
is if a if a bicycle takes the
initiative to go into a live
intersection and they misjudge it who's
liable for that collision and where is
it codified into law thank you for the
question uh I work a lot with lawyers
and on the defense side but I'm not a
lawyer so that's that's not a question
that I'd be comfortable answering uh I
deal with the rules of the road and the
infrastructure SES
things any other questions from the
committee pres of St Clair thank you Mr
chair you know my question any any
knowledge of uh
ticketing going on or strong
enforcement U for
bicycles coasting through I should have
answered that when I started but uh no I
am not aware I've never been ticketed um
and I'm not aware of any enforcement of
that I think it like people have
testified I think it's pretty common
practice for bicyclist and um and others
that when they recognize they're an
intersection and and they're not getting
a green light um or there's no traffic
that they they'll pass through thank you
any other questions representative
emblem uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you for taking that questions um so we
had a bill on motorcycle Lane filtering
currently uh at intersections where
there were no designated bike lane uh
bicycles allowed to do that same Lane
filtering technique or do they have to
stay in line with other vehicles
uh thank you for the question I'd have
to look through the rules of the road
I'm not aware that they're allowed to do
that I I see that fairly frequently um
I've been in a bite coming up to it to
signalize intersection where it's
uncomfortable to be in the queue uh and
I I would tend to be to the side one way
or the other um but I'm not sure what
the what the rules of the road would say
on that thank you any other questions
from the committee not seeing any thank
you
sir with that I do not have any other
pink cards but before I close off this
hearing just want to let everyone know
online we had 37 people who voted to
support this bill and seven who opposed
it so just to kind of give you a note on
that so with that I'm going to close the
hearing on HP
249 next up will be HP 411 just give us
a couple
minutes
e e
all right we're falling a little bit
behind here so we got to get get
moving like to
introduce HB 411 relative to making the
use of a mobile electronic device while
driving a secondary offense Cher like to
recognize representative Reed the prime
sponsor welcome thank you again Mr chair
and thank you again honorable members um
again for the record I am still Ellen
Reed I still represent Rockingham 10 new
market and newfields and as I've
testified in this committee before for
the context for the following bill um
among my many professions I've had in my
life the one I currently hold and I've
held for the last 14 years is that of a
CDL driver of large Vehicles interstate
and um in the 14 years I've helped that
license I have driven approximately 1
million
miles so as you are probably aware a
recent Supreme Court decision just
struck down at least part of our current
um handsfree law as overly Broad and not
really enforceable and unfair
um the way that the opinion as I read it
is directing is that it's unfair because
essentially
this is no different than this and yet
for some reason this is illegal and puts
points on your license and this does
not not that distracted driving which is
not illegal in and of itself the only
place in uh motor vehicle law where the
word distracted pops up is in the test
that we have to take to get our license
where we have to answer questions about
distracted
driving um but it's not that they're
saying that it's okay to distracted on
your phone they're saying that if you're
not doing something with your phone
that's
distracting and wouldn't be distracting
in any other context then that's not
enforcable um and so this mandates that
the law be changed now I understand why
the current law was written the way it
is because as I recall there were many
iterations trying to get to what would
be problematic behavior on your phone
and I remember things like well what you
know pressing a one button on your phone
more than once every 30 seconds and
obviously an officer cannot possibly
witness that level of detail with
operating the phone I mean I guess it's
possible but it's highly unlikely be
very difficult to enforce and so I think
the easiest thing for back then 10 years
ago for this committee to do was to
Simply say handsfree don't touch your
any device that can connect um
uh while you are
driving however um that's not that we
know now and I think the Supreme Court
has affirmed the intent of this bill
which is that is really unfair because I
could hold a phone shaped toy and that
would be fine I could do that to my face
and that would be fine I can eat my
breakfast I can put on my makeup in the
mirror which would be way worse than
doing this
and I have one of the largest phones on
the market and yet um the way our law is
is that that that is not distracted
driving and that is so this is what the
Supreme Court has said I did not have
foresight to know how they would decide
the case um relative to our former
colleague um but I think that the point
is that the this bill I think is an
elegant way to get around the idea that
you need to tie the behavior to being
actually
distracted um without creating all of
those enforcement problems of a officer
has to see you actually pushing a thing
or whatever um because by making it a
secondary offense only it has to be tied
to some other illegal Behavior whether
that's swerving following too closely
erratic driving speeding your lights
aren't on whatever it is this I think
gives office officers a lot of leeway to
say okay you're doing something that you
shouldn't be doing and also I saw you
potentially distracted and so now you
can connect that behavior having said
that if this committee decides that um
you need to clean that up you now have a
really convenient um timely uh
applicable vehicle for amending the
current law so um yeah I realize that
there are um representatives of our fine
law enforcement officers here uh ready
to tell you this would be exceedingly
dangerous and people will die and all of
those things and I will just say what I
said just a few minutes ago which is the
people are already doing the illegal
behaviors we aren't adequately
describing behaviors that people are
engaging in currently and the Supreme
Court has affirmed that so people are
already on their phone everybody is
seeing people on their
phone uh people are already getting
tickets for being on their phone whether
they're just holding a dead phone or um
you know holding something up to their
ear or actually texting which would be
the actual problematic Behavior right um
they're already doing that I think we
know now we have a mandate from the
Supreme Court to tighten up our law and
I think this allows officers to easily
enforce while still connecting it to the
actual distracted
driving
um I think oh I did want to say in the
interest stuff if in case you wanted to
talk about distracted driving which is
not currently its own RSA um the
National Highway Traffic and safety
administration defines distracted
driving is taking your eyes off the road
for two seconds or more again that' be
really hard for an officer to time or
whatever but just wanted to put that out
there for you and I think that might be
everything I have to to say off the bat
I did actually it's not illegal don't
get mad at me you can be mad but don't
get mad at me I wrote the bullet points
for my introduction while I was driving
so any any any questions when the
committee presentent V thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question do you do you know exactly what
the Supreme Court decision was and what
the behavior was that they were dealing
with yes and actually it was a behavior
by a former colleague of ours um that uh
I've also been pulled over though not
ticketed for which is holding a phone
that is not you're not actually
operating now in the EX in my example I
was picked up a phone to it had fallen
out of my bag onto the seat and I picked
it up to put it back in the seat in the
in the bag um in the example of our
former colleague he was on Bluetooth on
the Bluetooth device so he was not
operating the phone but the phone I
think had fallen down and he picked it
up he it fell down and he picked it up
and he was holding a phone but not
engaging with the phone and currently
officers do pull over and ticket people
for holding a phone even if it's powered
off it's capable of connecting to the
internet capable of sending and
receiving messages and therefore just
holding the phone even if it's broken
just holding the phone is a violation
that can put points on your license 150
for the first offense 250 for second
offense but holding this was fine that
was cool this morning follow
up so how that would
probably fall under the negligent
driving law in the state are you
familiar with that law I don't see how
that's negligent driving it's a
violation of the handsfree law but the
uh our former colleague was as far as I
know and it's would have been brought up
in the the case I think if there had
been otherwise was not engaged in any
other problematic driving
behavior no I just mean
that um any behavior that distracts you
and causes an accident would fall under
the the negligent driving law which
would technically be a I don't believe
you can be pulled over for negligent
driving until we do do something
actually negligent that would require
you to be you know cited or or something
along those lines
so where do you have kind of a secondary
law well place I for for that kind of
for the kind of behavior that would
cause problem so he wasn't cited for
negligent driving um and if if holding
an item was negligent driving then I
think all of us that drink our coffee in
the morning on the way to work would get
cited for negligent driving or put on
our makeup or whatever but that's not
happening so at some point despite
having negligent driving we decided
actually some point being 10 years ago
we decided that phones in particular
were a problem and indeed they are and
we wanted to create a special law for
that behavior because it was such a
problem which indeed it is and what I'm
saying is
that some of the behaviors with phones
that we have included in that law
because it's too hard for officers to
see exactly what you're doing on your
phone some of those behaviors are not
distracted driving and are not
problematic are not negligent and the
Supreme Court has upheld that so we need
to whatever else you think of me in my
driving and my professional million
miles and whatever else you think of
anyone's driving the Supreme Court has
said we need to clean up our law so you
don't have to go with it working as a
secondary offense if this committee
doesn't want to but you do have a
vehicle no pun to go ahead and amend the
law in a timely way because the Supreme
Court just made this
decision representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman and thank you representative
for taking my question while you asked
that I'm going to pick up my phone
because it's kind of freaking
out do I understand um that if this law
if your bill were to pass um and an
officer did see you doing what you said
is um the the idea that we were supposed
to avoid um he would not be able to stop
you and ticket you unless you were doing
something else like were swerving or
driving too close or something like that
correct and the committee's welcome to
amend that and kind of try to delineate
those two behaviors in particular again
that's why the language is how is is
because it's very hard for officers to
see exactly but I will say that you have
many of us well I don't have new car I
have very old car with 400,000 miles on
it but Toyota but many of us have a
large screen that we operate on the
vehicle right and that touching that is
fine and if we put this in a holder
being a much smaller and again I have
one of the largest ones being a much
smaller screen we are now leaning in to
try to see what's on our screen rather
than holding it here in the field of
view of the road in a more convenient
and Safe Way um all because it's we're
not allowed to hold it in our hand
so this is a problem but
this is less of a problem than
this okay thank you yep any other
questions representative
Johnson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question uh the court
case that you're referring to what is
the name of
that well I know that the name I guess
it' be State
vhole I presume I I I don't have it
memorized off the top of my head but
certainly holes in the in the name of
the case followup followup I believe it
was in the union leader article as well
over the last week or so okay thank you
um so if an officer sees you driving
down the road doing this and you're not
looking at the road they still can't
pull you over in in this no because what
you're doing let's say you're doing this
but you're doing this for two seconds or
less right so by the national traffic
and safety administration that's not
technically distracted driving so at
least in terms of your field of view so
um having said that I'm not it's not
like I'm sitting here going it has to be
this or nothing I'm repeatedly saying
you know you need to change the law this
is an elegant way to change the law if
you want to further delineate between um
you know pressing buttons on your phone
as opposed to pressing buttons on the
car as opposed to like dealing with a
radio as opposed to whatever then that's
up to the committee but the committee 10
years ago tried this and couldn't figure
out a good way to give officers an easy
thing to enforce what this does is say
if you're not doing anything else
dangerous on the road then maybe it's
not distracted driving perhaps this
committee wants to try the two second
thing or 3 second or whatever and say
that officers should be looking and
Counting how many seconds a person is
not looking at the road in that case you
could wrap in behaviors like writing
your speech beforehand or putting on
makeup I did not put on makeup in while
I was driving by the
way any other questions from the
committee representative H uh thank you
Mr chairman uh thank you representative
for being here today um in your
testimony you've given a lot of example
about levels of distracted drive and
using phone and your notebook Etc which
is fine um
so what does your bill actually do other
than make this a secondary offense to
the correct any behaviors
or uh prevent any problems well it
brings our law into line with the
Supreme Court decision and I think
that's valuable in and of itself um but
no it makes it a secondary offense it
does not I am not proposing that this is
going to get rid of an already existing
in our current law the current law
that's overly broad be as Su Supreme
Court case the already existing
distracted driver problem that is a real
problem that needs to be dealt with
dealt with perhaps via law but also
education also many different things can
be used to deal with that I'm not
proposing that I'm dealing with that
problem I'm proposing I'm dealing with
the problem of people who are not
distracted getting tickets because the
law is overly Broad and if I had come
here before The Supreme Court decision
was made I would have it just would have
been me with my million miles
professional telling you that there are
people being ticketed for an overly
broad law when they're not being
distracted but now I have the Supreme
Court backing me up which are words that
I rarely get to
say thank any other questions not seeing
any thank you so much
let the committee know we have five
other speakers on this particular Talk
of the
speech Mr chair do we have anybody from
uh State Police or anybody else that's
going to testify that's who's coming up
next thank you very much we have that do
as well chair like now recognize
Lieutenant Chris Storm from the New
Hampshire State Police asking for about
three to four minutes who has opposed
the bill welcome lieutenant
how's that better my name is Lieutenant
Chris storm I uh I represent the New
Hampshire State Police in the department
of safety uh my current position with
the state police is I am charged with
special services and also the liais onto
the uh office of Highway Safety um the
New Hampshire State Police and
Department of Safety obviously oppose
this law um we are struggling every
single day to stop distracted driving
which is one of the leading causes of
fatal crashes throughout our country um
the Nitsa um studies all show that this
is a massive problem
along our roadways um we feel that that
the law is already written uh properly
the law is um is very in tune to what's
going on out there and this was that
Supreme Court case was a very narrow um
situation um that indeed that uh that
gentleman was just simply holding a
phone and not actively using it uh we
understand that that's why we have
discretion that's why we have uh we were
able to talk to people once we're up to
to their vehicles but overall we need
that law to help keep everybody on New
Hampshire roadway safe by if they're
manipulating that phone if they are
distracted to rep uh representative V's
um Point um absolutely if you are
actively doing something that is
distracting you um it is absolutely
under that negligent driving statute uh
26579 B um and that we can actually take
action if you are doing something that's
distracting that's causing a collision
or anything else that's uh um
predominantly bad on our roadways and I
be more than willing to answer any
questions that anybody
has thank you sir any questions from the
committee representative St Clair thank
you Mr chair and thank you Trooper uh if
you were if you OBS observe somebody or
somebody in the department observed
somebody uh driving and they had their
head looking
down potentially at their lap or
something uh would that be potentially
probable cause to pull them over not
necessarily you'd actually have to see
that device actually see them actually
doing something if you're just simply
looking down unfortunately there's no
law that says just looking down is a
crime thank you any other questions from
the committee no representative ve thank
you Mr chairman thank you taking my
question is it obvious when somebody is
just holding something versus when
they're actively engaging it and
manipulating it yes AB absolutely we
definitely will see somebody actually
manipulating that particular device or
something there that would draw our
attention to stop that
vehicle any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you
lieutenant thank you chair now i' like
to recognize Jim Moody from the New
Hampshire
mro who opposes the bill asking for
about two to three
minutes welcome
sir thank you Mr
chairman and committee members for this
opportunity to convey our views on HB
411 uh my name is Jim Moody I am the
incoming vice president of the New
Hampshire motorcyclist rights
organization commonly referred to as
nimro U and on behalf of nimro I am
opposing HB 411 I for a few reasons why
nimro believes retaining the use of a
mobile electronic device while driving U
should be remain as a primary offense uh
other testimonies been given about
distracted driving uh distracted driving
is any activity that um diverts
attention from driving including talking
or texting eating and drinking talking
to people in your vehicle fiddling with
your stereo entertainment nav system
anything that takes your attention away
from the task of safe driving texting
obviously um is the most alarming
distraction sending a reading a te text
takes your eyes off the road for 5
seconds on average um at 55 miles an
hour uh that's like driving the length
of an entire football field with your
eyes closed uh using a cell phone while
driving creates enormous potential for
deaths and injury on on us roads
according to Nitsa in 2022 3,38 people
were killed in motor vehicle crashes
involving distracted drivers this
accounts for between 8 and 9% of all
fatal motor vehicle collisions on roads
across the US to put that in perspective
a total of nine people every day in the
US are uh killed uh from distracted
driving however not all distracted
driving crashes are fatal the total of
driver distraction is far greater
considering crashes that caused injury
but were not fatal in fact
324,000 Hampshire in
2024 while our vehicles have become
safer that doesn't mean our roads are
safe from distracted drivers distraction
affects driver performance by causing
reduced Reaction Time impaired
decision-making decreased situational
awareness and compromise vehicle control
motorcycles are at particularly high
risk for collisions when drivers are
cognitively distracted thank you for for
your time and I hope that you would
consider our statements on this bill and
oppose HB 411
thank you sir any questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you I
also have written testimony to help pass
out
thank chair now like to recognize Dan
Bennett asking for one minute who
opposes the bill from the New Hampshire
Auto Dealers
Association welcome sir to
Transportation thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee I think I
indicated two minutes but I'll do my
best to keep it to one so um as you know
NADA is a trade associ for the motor
vehicle industry car truck motorcycle
snowmobile ATV construction farm
equipment uh both franchise and
independent in all corners of the state
um as you've heard from us before
roadway safety is a a Cornerstone issue
for NADA uh on on multiple issues uh
over 10 years ago we worked with the
Department of Safety um and the other
stakeholders to help craft this language
uh specifically at the time it was Major
Shapiro uh from the office of Highway
Safety um and a lot of work went into
the to the language um there is
increased dangerous activity and and
accidents on the roads in New Hampshire
you know Union Leader uh this weekend
individuals stopped going 125 mil hour
on 93 uh excessive speeding uh you've
heard us talk about for last year was
the deadliest year on the roads for
youth operators um and so this is no
time to weaken uh our our laws that
affect roadway safety the three big
issues really are distraction um
impairment and speed okay so the three
legs of that stool uh it's it's no time
to to weaken one of those legs um and if
the committee did so feel uh necessary
to TW tweak the law based on the recent
Supreme Court decision um then we would
gladly work as a stakeholder and
participate um including that in the the
perspective of some of the newer vehicle
technology uh that we find in our cars
and and trucks so um with that being
said that's all we wanted to U offer
that we do in fact oppose the Bill thank
you sir any questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you thank
you chair I would like to recognize Dan
Goodman from Triple A asking for two to
three
minutes opposes the bill does have some
written
testimony uh welcome sir to
Transportation thank you very much chair
uh for the record my name is Dan Goodman
I'm the public affairs and traffic
safety manager for Tria Northern New
England um come here in opposition to
this bill um I I'll try to be quick
because I know we're running late um
triaa has a foundation AAA foundation
for Traffic Safety that is the has done
about a dozen studies on distracted
driving and I'm just going to lay out a
couple key points about the dangers of
distracted driving that we have studied
in conjunction with the University of
Utah over the years any cell phone use
quadruples your crash risk cognitive
distraction which means you're not
looking at the phone but anytime you use
your phone you have a mental distraction
in other words cognitive distraction is
real and even with your hands on the
wheel and your eyes on the road these
distractions dangerously affect your
driving performance texting creates a
crash R crash risk 23 times worse than
driving while not distracted with one
out of every 20 drivers using a cell
phone at any given time on the roads um
it's extremely dangerous drivers also in
our latest study drivers experience
what's known as a hangover effect a
lasting distraction that lasts up to 27
seconds after you hang up your cell
phone even so when you're at and this is
they test that when people are at stop
signs or at red lights when they're
texting or using their
phone they they hang up and they have a
hangover effect it's still a mental
distraction that in some instances led
to 27 seconds of continued
distraction we do an annual survey
across the country it's called the triaa
foundation Traffic Safety culture index
last year 93% of respondents cited
distraction as a serious problem and a
behavior that makes them feel less safe
on the road a year ago or two years ago
the year before it was
83% and that's people are just feeling
less safe on the roads and distraction
is one of the largest issues and I also
I'm going to follow Dan Bennett I also
have a stool analogy improving it's it
traffic safety is founded on three e you
need strong enforcement you need an
effective law and you also have to have
an education
campaign think of this concept as a
three-legged stool if one leg is missing
or damaged that schol is weakened and
unsafe passing this law weakens that
that one leg thus making our roads in
New Hampshire less safe um I I urg you
to in to vote in opposition to this and
happy to answer any questions thank you
any questions from the committee not
seeing any thank you thank you written
testimony do you have the written
testimony I apologize you do not you not
okay yeah that was a mischaracterization
sorry
chair now like to recognize Bill Bennett
from the Hampshire do asking one to two
minutes who doesn't take any position on
the bill welcome back
sir thank you Mr chairman that's Bill
Lambert um not
Bennett um so for the record Bill
Lambert New Hampshire do Highway um
safety act of Transportation
administrator and do does not have a
position on this bill a couple quick
antidotes uh long before Lieutenant
storm was in State Police I remember
Lieutenant Susan fory telling an
anecdote 2004 when the Red Sox Run the
World Series of pulling somebody over on
i93 that was watching the Red Sox on the
laptop that their passenger was um was
um open and holding and that person was
very disappointed that they got a ticket
for distracted driving because it was
the Red Sox and they were in the World
Series um so distracted driving has been
a serious issue for a while uh I know
the Department of Transportation adopted
our our internal um self phone use
policy and we recognize that it's not I
think it's the cognitive uh distraction
that Dan Goodman recently talked about
um it's not just the the use of the
phone and the physical use of the phone
it's a cognitive distraction in our
policy before there was a handsfree law
in the state was that any cell phone use
uh during a vehicle whether you're
handsfree or not was going to be um was
going to be prohibited ironically the
first person to get um discipline for
for violating that policy was out then
commissioner that signed it uh when he
was spotted by employees for U having a
cell phone in his hand and he wrote
himself a letter of warning so again we
don't have a position on this but we
recognize and we support our enforcement
um um Partners in highway safety because
distraction is a very serious problem on
our highways our folks that are working
on the road that that's their office
space see it every day uh the people
that are going by of them are not paying
attention to what they're doing and it's
it's not just for the General Highway
Safety we um we're concerned about our
own employees safety and with that I'd
take any
questions thank you sir any questions
from the committee representative St
Clair thank you Mr chair and thank you
um I should have asked the the last
speaker about this but I'm curious in
your field have you ever heard about
this hangover effect of using a cell
phone or for that matter listening to
the news on the radio or anything when
you're driving um the cognitive
distraction on very well aware of but I
can be distracted when I'm driving with
talking to my wife in the passenger seat
fortunately in that case my wife will
remind me to pay attention to the road
um but I I have heard of The Hangover
effect I've probably heard it from from
Mr Goodman and in other conversations
but it's it seems intuitive to me that
when you're having a conversation and
you hang up you still thinking about
that conversation um so and I don't have
any data I'm sure U Mr Goodman has more
data than I um but I have her of
B followup followup thank you um but do
you not agree that that hangover effect
could be listening to a news report that
upsets you on the
radio certainly uh for the last 10 years
I if not listen to any kind of voice
radio I have 10,000 songs from my
library on my phone and that's all I
listen to on the vehicle U and and
that's part of the reason why I mean it
was a while when I was listening to talk
radio where I could feel myself being
engaged and agitated so I certainly
understand that thank you any other
questions from the committee not seeing
any thank
you I don't have any other uh pin cards
for anybody else to testify and just to
kind of wrap up in terms of online
constituents supported this bill nine
and six opposed so with that I'm going
to close the public hearing on HB 411
next bill is HB 441 we'll stop that in
about two
minutes
e e
all right being about 11:22 like to open
up the public hearing on HB
441 relative to visible motor vehicle
diesel emissions and rolling coal chair
like to recognize representative heat
Howard uh who's the Prime sponsor of the
bill who supports the bill sir welcome
to Transportation thank you honorable Mr
chair and committee members uh I
apologize that I was a few minutes late
uh I have committee going on right now
uh upstairs uh but HB 441 prohibits the
operation of diesel vehicles under1
18,000 with altered exhaust systems that
emit excessive smoke uh commonly known
as rolling coal it is a step towards
safeguarding Public Health reducing
environmental harm and promoting
responsible vehicle use this ban uh this
would ban the intentional modification
of vehicles to emit thick plumes of
smoke and by Banning this practice this
the bill directly mitigates localized
air pollution protecting vulnerable
populations like children the elderly
and those with pre-existing health
conditions uh black carbon the major
component of De uh diesel smoke has a
global warming potential of up to uh
3,300 times greater than carbon dioxide
over 20 year period reducing black
carbon emissions is a cost-effective
strategy to slow near-term climate
warming this bill aligns with broader
efforts such as the diesel emissions
reduction Act passed uh federally back
in 2010 uh which prioritized
retrofitting diesel engines uh to curve
emissions uh prohibiting rolling coal
ensures that individual actions do not
undermine Collective climate goals
excessive smoke from rolling coal
impairs visibility for drivers cyclists
and pedestrians increasing accident
risks the bill reinforces civic
responsibility by penalizing deliberate
actions that endangers others uh and
reinforces civic responsibility by
penalizing deliberate actions that
endanger others Modern Diesel engines
are equipped with uh emission controls
such as uh particulate filters uh which
already achieve near zero plent
levels this law ensures that vehicle
modifications do not revert to outdated
harmful practices by preventing the
intentional use of smoke in a harmful
manner this bill is also less extreme
than some of the other laws passed
elsewhere in the United States by uh
creating this as a violation and not a
felony uh with that I'm open to any
questions thank you thank you sir any
questions from the
committee representative St Clair thank
you Mr chair uh um and thank
you when that smoke comes
out and it's in the air how long does it
take if you know the answer
to dissipate in other words you don't
see it anymore that's a good question
I'm not fully certain I mean it depends
on how long somebody is uh uh trying to
push that smoke out and obviously uh it
can take quite a while to dissipate
thank you we do have someone from the
New Hampshire Dees up to speak so they
may be able to answer that
question any other questions from the
committee representative hble thank you
Mr chair uh thank you representative for
being here taking that questions um so
just to be clear in order to be able to
produce this black smoke is the only way
to do that through an a modification of
the exhaust system uh I believe so it
needs to be it's either going to be an
older diesel motor or it's going to be
one that has been uh Modified by the
owner
uh meaning that they would have
intentionally violated this uh statute
thank you any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you thank
you chair now i' like to recognize
Michael Fitzgerald from the New
Hampshire Dees who's not taking any
position on the bill who's asking for
two minutes welcome S
Transportation thank you very much Mr
chairman uh stated Michael fitzgeral
assistant director of the uh air
Resources Division of the Department of
Environmental Service Services uh as
I've mentioned previously we work with
the Department of Safety to implement
the vehicle emissions uh control program
here in the state and uh I we do not
take a position on this bill I do not
disagree with anything that the sponsor
said uh previously uh relative to
emissions uh I just wanted to point out
that there already are statutes that
address this issue um there are anti
there are both federal and state
anti-tampering
um uh statutes uh and and uh rules uh
currently uh rule uh safety rule uh
32220 4 uh prohibits tampering uh of a
missions equipment on a vehicle it's
also prohibited under the missions
control program under RSA
26659 which also authorizes the
department of safety to conduct capacity
testing uh on uh on trucks and vehicles
uh I believe this bill is intended to
address smaller vehicles um but um uh we
do have that program and people can
complain to the state police um file
complaints and um have those have those
followed up um that no way I I don't
intend to say this bill isn't necessary
again we're not taking a position I just
wanted the committee to be aware that uh
those uh statutes and and those programs
um that that do exist already and I'd be
happy to address any questions thank you
sir any questions from the committee
representative
patero thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question um I want to make sure that
what this bill is talking about is what
I'm imagining it is okay
so we're it it's
addressing a specific situation where
where
people have a diesel vehicle and they
modify the exhaust system on the diesel
vehicle to have black
smoke simply for a visual effect is that
what this bill is talking about uh to
the best of my knowledge yes I'm I'm not
uh an expert on rolling coal but the
term as I understand it is uh where
people alter the emissions system so
that they can at certain times um uh
emit large amounts of dark black smoke
um and uh uh have it impact Vehicles
behind
them thank you uh quick followup Mr
chair follow up thank you
um when I when I was younger and riding
in the back seat with my parents all
over everywhere you know you had logging
trucks and Mac trucks and bigger trucks
I realized they're probably over 18,000
Pounds right yeah
um but but those trucks exhausts back in
those days would be shooting black AB
you know um you you said that this was
um below a certain weight capacity
earlier in your testimony am I on the
right train of thought here with
imagining this whole bill uh yes I
believe the the bill refers to vehicles
under
18,000 um and uh uh I I certainly
understand what you're talking about um
you know older diesel vehicles certainly
do emit can can emit uh significant
amounts of black smoke that's the intent
of the opacity uh regulation that we
have on the books now and the opacity
testing that that can be conducted by
the department of safety and uh um also
I would just point out that diesel
vehicles over the last 20 years have uh
you know cleaned up tremendously um
there's there's a the sponsor of the
bill mentioned there was a uh uh there's
been significant Improvement in the
emissions controls and so on however
there are still a lot of those Vehicles
diesel vehicles can last 20 30 40 years
depending on the mileage they can be
rebuilt Etc so um there's still a large
number of those Vehicles out there um
but I think this is intended to address
that specific intentional Act of rolling
Co thank you so much any other questions
from the
committee not seeing any thank you thank
you I do not have anybody else I pink uh
Pink cards for this bill but just to let
everybody know online we had 17
constituents who supported this bill and
three that opposed so with that I'm
going to close the hearing on HB 441
next one up would be HB 46 461 which
will start in about two
minutes
e e
okay being 11:33 I'm going to open up
the public hearing on HB
461 relative to Department of Safety and
Department of Motor Vehicle training and
testing materials
the chair like to representative like to
recognize representative foot who will
be introducing the
bill good morning thank you Mr chair and
colleagues at the committee I am here on
behalf of Representative Walsh who
cannot make it this morning to um
introduce his bill which is House Bill
461 relative to Department of Safety and
Department of Motor Vehicle training and
testing material
materials um give you a quick snobs if
it pulls up on
me so essenti the quick analysis on this
is this bill requires all printed and
digitally available driver's license
examination related materials including
the examination itself be available and
administered in the English language
only thank
you thank you Sarah any questions from
the committee very nice to you today
that's
good chair now i' like to recognize uh
William
gallette hopefully not from The
International Institute of New
England uh a requesting three minutes
who opposes the bill has written
testimony welcome sir to a
Transportation uh thank you uh Mr
chairman and thank you to the committee
for giving me this opportunity uh my
name is William gillet I'm the director
of public policy and advocacy for The
International Institute of New England
with an office in Manchester uh first
let me reference a letter the committee
has received from the New Hampshire
immigrant rights Network detailing legal
and practical concerns with the proposed
legislation I'm a co-signer on that and
fully agree with the points set out in
the letter my remarks today will address
a very practical concern with this bill
that our clients have
experienced uh driver's license in New
Hampshire is not a privilege it's a
necessity we do not have the population
to support extens of bus or rail service
to live in New Hampshire to thrive in
New Hampshire to work in New Hampshire
requires you to drive in New Hampshire
specifically according to the Census
Bureau only 0.3% of New Hampshire
residents use public transportation to
get to work we all want safe roads
traveled by only licensed drivers who
have demonstrated their ability to
operate their vehicle in accordance with
the laws of our state we also want New
Hampshire residents to be able to fully
participate in our economy and our
Workforce to contribute to the public
good and to be able to provide for
themselves and their families without
relying on the state for support this
bill would prevent many New Hampshire
residents from being able to do exactly
that
I don't pretend to understand the
motives behind this bill if it is to
encourage new arrivals in our state to
learn English I can assure you that no
punitive encouragement is needed at The
International Institute in Manchester we
offer at any given time 10 esol courses
uh to beginners intermediate and
advanced Learners with up to 25 students
in each and we currently have over 200
students on the wait list if the goal is
to encourage immigrants to in the state
to learn English fund more esol training
the carrot will work better than the
stick in this endeavor every immigrant
who comes to New Hampshire no matter
where they are coming from is here for
the opportunity for a better life than
where they're from despite the
attractiveness at life here for a recent
study by New Hampshire employment
security office the state has fewer
immigrants per capita than much of the
rest of the country specifically foreign
born residents accounted for a smaller
share of New Hampshire's population
6.8% approximately half the share of the
overall US population among foreign born
New Hampshire residents
61% were naturalized citizens compared
to 52% of foreign born us residents to
continue to and Thrive and grow New
Hampshire needs immigrants who are more
likely to be in their Prime working
years than other M migrants from the
report 65% of residents who had moved
from abroad between 2017 and 2022 were
between the ages of 18 and 44 compared
to 34% of the total State uh
population the report States immigrants
are a productive and crucial part of the
New Hampshire economy this bill by
restricting some immigrants ability to
obtain a driver's license delays entry
to needed employes into the workforce
and means others will be underemployed
being restricted to those jobs that
require them to rely on limited public
transport or other less reliable options
to get to work we need to encourage and
support all New Hampshire residents to
be productive and to thrive in our
economy and there is no reason to impede
their progress by requiring them to be
proficient enough in English to pass a
driver's license test most are striving
to learn English to find and hold better
paying careers economic and social
opportunities are more than sufficient
incentive for immigrants to learn
English we need to support them not
hinder them thank you for consideration
and I'm open to any questions any
questions from the
committee representative St Clair thank
you Mr chair thank you any other states
that do this to your knowledge uh none
that I'm aware of there are federal
requirements specifically uh that would
generally discourage this thank
you any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you sir
thank
you do you have written testimony oh
yeah you want to
submit guys any a
question uh no did I have no other
cards pataro question for the chair um
anyone from DMV coming for this no I
have nobody else who's listed to
speak um yeah do you do you have a
question for yes for the DMB
yeah where chair like to recognize
director
rasco from the
MV just going to ask who's going to here
for informational testimony ask in a few
minutes morning Mr chair member of the
committee committee thank you uh for
this opportunity to speak to you and um
representative pataro happy to uh put in
a a card so I can answer any questions
that you have sir oh absolutely
wonderful um if I may Mr chair can you
okay um
at the federal level I'm I'm aware of uh
stuff like this
and um there was also talk of like there
there's already federal regulations in
regards to this um the the area of
though of law that I'm familiar with it
is has to do with um uh voting actually
so to my
knowledge the the United States of
America does not have an official
language is there a question here
representative yeah
[Music]
um the United States of America does not
have an official language and the reason
we don't have an official language is so
that voting
ballots can't be printed in English only
that's the extent of my knowledge and
and for my question for for for you is
is
are we
printing the tests in different
languages and we're allowed the leeway
to do that because the federal
government does not have an official
language fair question thank you sir um
so at the DMV um and contracts were
pulled yesterday in anticipation of of
being um asked to testify here today of
what we currently offer so uh over 10
years ago the DMV um made a decision to
pay for and to offer uh Knowledge Test
the computer-based test in different
languages um those languages are Spanish
French American Sign Language Portuguese
Mandarin English Farsi and Arabic um so
we have customers who come in um that
utilize those services to take their
Knowledge Test over the computer and um
either pass or fail based on their
knowledge of the um driving laws that
you need to get the 80% to pass the test
um the other thing that we've done uh
more recently to try to complement that
is we worked with the New Hampshire
office of Highway Safety and Dan Goodman
at Triple A um to provide for manuals
the driver manual which the New
Hampshire driver's manual is where the
questions come from so if you've studied
the driver's manual you're going to do
very well on the on the Knowledge Test
when you come in um so in order to uh
serve the community and we have monthly
community outreach meetings at the DMV
where we hear from community members and
concerns um challenges that that uh
community members face um so we took a
look at those seven knowledge
tests and thanks to the office of
Highway Safety in trip triaa we were
able to secure funding to print the
driver's manual uh in five different
languages that would help align with
those knowledge tests uh and that would
be sili span Portuguese Mandarin and
Arabic um the proactive rationale for
doing that was that we see what's
happening on the roadways today and the
number of crashes the deaths um and
giving individuals that are going to
come in and take the knowledge test that
information and being better prepared
being able to digest the information to
make them presumably a better driver on
the roadway um was something that we um
we looked at to uh to try to serve the
community and if I could just go back to
representative St Clair's question I
have spoken with the MV directors
throughout North America uh with regards
to either not so much bills that would
do what this bill intends to do but
other DMVs and I've testified to this
before other DMVs around the country do
have uh tests that are offered in a
multitude of different languages uh some
provide for the driver's manual in
different languages some do it in
different ways some do it the way that
we did it through a contract so that you
have an accurate uh translation so word
for word that is um signed off on and
certified so that that way there nobody
reads something the wrong way or takes
the test and gets something wrong
because it wasn't translated properly in
the manual uh other states um simply use
Google Translate on their website to
translate their manual but the problem
with that is it's not always accurate um
so other states around the country the
vast majority um do provide for these
Services um and one other thing
represented you mentioned I the the
federal piece I know that there's
written testimony here today um but uh
one thing that did catch my attention
was I received a PowerPoint presentation
from John CLE uh the program manager in
the office of Highway Safety and um in
that PowerPoint apparently was put it
was put out by Nitsa in
2025 um and IT addresses the Civil
Rights Act of
1964 in that PowerPoint it talks about
uh nit of grants that are extended to uh
and it actually uses DMV uh as an
example in the PowerPoint um grants that
are issued to the agency even if it's
just for one person um you're subject to
the parameters of the Grant and per um
the Civil Rights Act of 1964 if you've
got a population of customer within your
state substantial customer population
that would require language
accessibility um because there's limited
uh English proficiency in order to stay
in compliance with the grant um you
would need to provide that um so the DMV
actually is in compliance with that we
do have one Grant funded position within
the organization from Nitsa um and that
person is Ian Marsh who oversees um all
the fatal crashes that come in
throughout the state and captures that
information and presents it um on a a
weekly basis as to where we are going
with crashes so um those are just some
highlights to offer but um again happy
to take any questions if there are I
actually have a question you mentioned
these these languages you said Spanish
French Bary Mandarin AR
Arabic how many how many I guess how
many tests have been provided in these
languages do you have like numbers you
can share do I do Mr chair I don't have
them with me uh this this morning I do
have those numbers they were recently
run um they were run in order to
determine if if we were going to
translate these manuals Which languages
would be the manuals um we would want
the manuals translated uh into because
we went with the highest volume so I do
have those numbers for you I can provide
those to you um through an email and for
the committee yes representative Fox
thank you Mr chair um thank you director
morasco so in addition if this bill is
passed in addition to Spanish French
Portuguese Mandarin and
Arabic it would also
eliminate uh testing materials in sign
language that's is that correct uh
actually I think the bill makes a
provision for that if I'm not
mistaken thank you I'll look for
that
represent thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question um
hypothetical Bae hires a scientist that
speaks primarily French and they want
them to relocate to
NASA and they have 60 days do they have
60 days to tr get their license yes
converted so if they don't speak good
English and they're coming
here and they don't have an option to
take it in French how does BAE ensure
this person can travel and get to
work um thank you representative for the
question it it's I don't know how they
would ensure that um you know we we do
have and I'm going to get for the chair
the uh the actual numbers for um the
different languages and who takes the
test in those languages um but there are
a fair number of people that utilize
that opportunity the other thing that
that should be highlighted um should
this bill pass is there is a um a
section within the DMV rule set that
does provide for the opportunity for a
thirdparty translator uh to be present
with the test taker uh during the
knowledge exam so although these
languages the seven that we offer uh
if you are able to speak one of those
languages and the Knowledge Test is
beneficial to you to take um but what if
you're language number eight 10 11 um so
the rule set does allow for a thirdparty
translator for languages that we don't
offer to come in and assist with the
reading of the uh the exam um to help on
that front so uh I hope that answers
your question thank
you representative foot thank you Mr
chair thank you director for taking my
question Mr um so in today's world
there's a lot of signage roadways
highways things like that so and I know
signs are associated with like color
shapes sizes things like that is there
any data relative to any kind of issues
with interpretation whether it be
accidents or violations that somebody
who's non English speaking
misinterpreting a sign or not
understanding a sign do we have that
it's a good question sir I don't I don't
have that information off hand I don't
know I can tell you that when we went
through the process of securing the
contract and providing for the
translated manuals uh one of the things
that we had to make sure that we ensured
was uh that the signs just like when the
test is taken the signs are the signs
that we see out out here so the sign is
an octagon that says stop on it um it's
stop and even if your native language is
s you still have to recognize that that
means stop and that says stop in English
so the signs both in the manual for the
testing uh are going to be in the uh in
English so signs will have to be
recognized in English
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you mentioned the uh
third party
translators um does the state pay for
those when they are needed and if so
would this create an additional
financial burden for the people who
wanted to take the tests using the
languages that we would be
eliminating it's an excellent question
representative uh my understanding is
that at this
time translators are brought in by the
the candidate um so they they bring in a
um a third party translator of their
choosing um but you raised an
interesting point with regards to um
certainly de and heart of hearing um
that require assistance for that would
be uh incumbent upon the state to
provide that so this is an area that we
would we would have to look into
although I haven't been faced with
anything where we've been asked to
provide for it um and pay for it yet I'm
not aware of that thank you
representative
Crawford thank you Mr chairman uh good
morning
morning if a person um I'm following up
on uh representative REO if a person
comes from a foreign country and has a
license in that country do we have any
type of reciprocity or do they all have
to take an
exam well we have um although I haven't
seen the agreements uh I've asked for
them but I haven't been presented with
the actual agreements we have uh on the
books I'm told reciprocity with Canada
and France uh we are still working
through a reciprocity agreement with
Taiwan
um so those countries we have
reciprocity with um in in other
instances to representative Bay's point
it would be the if you establish the
residency within 60 days you'd have to
apply for the New Hampshire driver's
license follow followup if you have a to
follow up on that if you have a license
in France or or a country that we don't
have reciprocity with and you are going
to excuse me become a citizen within 60
days is it are you going to make make
them take the test and the driving test
yes okay thank you you're welcome any
other questions from the committee not
seeing any thank you sir for stepping in
there thank you Mr chair with that I
have uh no other pink cards so before I
close this hearing just want to share
numbers that we got online from our
constituents regarding this bill six
supported and 254 opposed just want to
throw that out there so with that I'm
going to close the hearing on hb4
61 next uh up in a couple minutes will
be
hb212 e
okay it be in
11:54 I'm going to open up the public
hearing on
hb212 allowing a 180-day operation
waiver when a motor vehicle fails an
emission control test chair like to
recognize representative Charles foot
who will int introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chairman good morning
uh members of the committee
representative Charles foot representing
Derry Rockingham 13 I'm here as courtesy
to represent um to introduce House Bill
212 allowing 180 day operation waiver
when a motor vehicle fails an emission
control test uh this is on behalf of
repr of Matt Coker quick analysis of
this bill extends the temporary wave for
permitting operation of a vehicle that
failed an EPA OBD2 emission control test
from 60 days to 180 days thank you thank
you any questions from the committee not
seeing any thank you
sir chair now like to recognize Dan
Bennett from the New Hampshire Auto
Dealers Association who supports the
bill asking for uh 2 minutes
Welcome Back
Sir uh Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify uh today in support of hb212
um as you know nhada is a trade
Association for the motor vehicle
industry uh here in New Hampshire um
we've always mentioned to this committee
uh that we support common sense if there
if there are changes to the inspection
emissions program uh we would support
Common Sense changes to the program uh
we always ask that you uh look at the
program with a scalpel not a hatchet uh
and this bill does exactly that it
provides consumer benefit giving a
little more time to save Monies to get
uh needed repairs um while it doesn't
weaken uh safety of the vehicles on the
roadways um you know we do acknowledge
that uh there may be some changes that
are needed to our state implementation
plan under the Clean Air Act uh so we
hope that you take care and caution with
that as there is Federal Highway funding
tied to uh Clean Air Act compliance uh
but the department of environment
services are the true experts on that um
so uh the only other thing that I that I
want to mention um that we do have a
little bit of concern and we hope that
you consider in giving this longer time
frame for emissions inspection repair
what you may find is uh games being
played in the private marketplace where
possibly battery cables are pulled the
check engine light goes on the vehicle
is then sold and transferred it's less
likely to happen in the um in the dealer
world uh because of our testing
equipment that we have uh to actually
monitor readiness ob2 check engine
lights um but we just kind of caution
that that there may be a negative impact
in the uh consumer Marketplace the front
yard sales um to unload a vehicle that
um was not uh properly repaired so other
than that um that's our testimony on
hb212 thank you sir any questions from
the committee representative
Johnson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um can you
please explain why 60 days is
insufficient and you need more
days thanks for the question question R
Johnson um you know some of the repairs
that are needed for uh OBD2 uh emissions
are a little more costly uh we're not
we're not always talking about an O2
fuel sensor or a misfitting gas cap at
times it could be catalytic converters
you know uh 122 $1,00 so more costly
repairs so this bill um it doesn't give
a complete waiver from from getting the
repair it just gives the citizen the
customer a little more time to bank some
money uh for that needed repair
any other questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you sir thank you
sir chair now like to recognize Jeremy
Olen who's supporting himself asking for
two minutes who supports the bill
welcome sir to
Transportation good morning members of
the transportation committee and thank
you for allowing me to testify on this
bill I actually here later to testify in
favor of HB 649 which is a much wider oh
can you introduce yourself please oh yes
um my name is my name is Jeremy Olson
and I live in Manchester w 11 so I'll be
here testifying later on HP 649 which is
a much wider scope on the inspection
stuff I just wanted to reiterate I would
support this bill also um I'll be
talking about this later in HP 649 but
there are tons of stories of people out
there where they have the check engine
light come on in their car and then it
doesn't pass inspection and these
repairs as the um the dealership guy
said these repairs can cost thousands of
dollars sometimes nowadays like with
supply chain issues sometimes it takes
the parts weeks or months to get here if
it's a foreign car things like that I've
had that proba happen myself with tires
even it took them two months to send
tires for my car at one point so when
you're dealing with complicated
Electronics it can be very expensive and
it can be very tedious to get it
repaired the 60 days is quite frankly
not enough for a lot of people nowadays
again to read Get Right like you said it
it costs a lot of money so expanding it
to six months would be very reasonable
for people to be able to deal with so
again I support this bill and um I'd be
happy to take any questions
thank you sir any questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much thank
you chair now i' like to recognize Steve
zamek who's representing
himself who is uh supporting the bill
welcome uh sir the
transportation hi thanks for having me
uh my name is Steve zanic I live in West
Manchester and W 11 um and I support
this bill and uh one of the main reasons
I I support this bill is I mean very
very frequently the problem's obvious
put the part in you're good to go uh but
sometimes the problem can be not so
clear-cut the uh the newer cars are
getting more and more sensitive to
different emissions things um and it
could be something as simple as a wire
that is sometimes broken and sometimes
connected and you're driving along and
you hit a bump and it disconnects for a
second and then reconnects next and then
when your mechanic is trying to go and
figure out what's going on everything
looks fine so so some people end up
throwing you know thousands of dollars
in Parts at the car just to get the
check engine light off um and also uh
you know if you have a California
emissions equipped car uh it's even more
sensitive than maybe the same exact
making model um that is from a you know
that does not have the California
missions package
um the other thing is is um if uh if you
make a repair sometimes you have to go
through a certain number of drive cycles
uh before it will actually pass
emissions um so for example I I had a
friend who had a um EVAP code which is
often just like a loose gas cap and it
was intermittent came on came went away
came on and then she had to go get her
inspection sticker um so I hunted down
the actual problem uh ordered the
parts uh took a while to get the
parts um replaced them and uh you know
everything seemed fine except it still
wasn't going into the What's called the
OBD ready um mode and I drove it around
like all day and it still wouldn't go
into OBD uh ready mode uh I went I went
through the uh I went I went to the
service manual and I discover discovered
that um for the EVAP code to go into OBD
ready you it would only do it if you
drove a certain distance with the
temperature was over 40 uh with the
temperature was over 40 so in the
middle of winter you're not going to get
it to go into OBD ready mode um uh
unless you find a extra warm day to
drive around on um so sometimes you know
it takes time just to hunt down a
problem or to get it ready for uh
emissions testing the other problem is
there have been people that they just
they tried everything to get the check
engine light off or for whatever reason
their car is not going to OBD ready mode
that doesn't necessarily mean their car
is um polluting so I do think one thing
that could improve the the program is if
there's some kind of appeal process
where we can say hey I don't think my
car is polluting can you actually test
it like the old school put
a sniffer in the tailpipe and see if
it's actually polluting or not um and
actually like scientifically measure
things because it might just be fine uh
and people are throwing thousands of
dollars at parts and their car is not
even polluting so uh oh and the other
thing is um and as cars are getting more
advanced with the emissions uh controls
on some new cars even the air
conditioner uh system is tied into OBD
so if you have a uh um if you have a
problem with your air conditioning
system and all the refrigerant uh leaks
out and you're like well I don't need uh
air conditioning it's cold here most of
the time anyway um you might need to go
and replace that air conditioning system
uh just because of that check engine
light or or the uh OBD Readiness uh
situation so um and the other thing is
um there have been cases for example
there was an article in the Boston Globe
uh where a guy bought a car in ASA brand
new car and uh a check engine light came
on and uh it took GM months to figure
out what was wrong on a brand new model
so there's a lot of different situations
that can put people into a situation so
giving them more time would uh be very
helpful thank you any questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you
sir okay i' like to recognize Michael
Fitzgerald from the New Hampshire de
s who has written testimony and looking
for about two to three minutes welcome
back sir thank you very much Mr chair
Michael Fitzgerald assistant
director uh air Resources Division
Department of Environmental Services I'm
also accompanied today by Jessica Wilcox
who uh manages our uh transportation and
energy related programs of which the
emissions program is one also um if
you're a fan of The Simpsons
uh as you've heard uh Professor Frank
say I'm here to restate my nerdy plight
once again um I uh uh the department uh
implements the motor vehicle inspection
program pursuant to the Clean Air Act we
did provide you with a letter of
testimony again very similar to what you
heard me say on HB
209 uh in order to revise the program
that is currently ins sconed in uh New
Hampshire statute and
uh also in our federally approved uh
State implementation plan with EPA
pursuant to the Clean Air Act um we
would need to apply to the EPA we would
need to to uh evaluate the emissions
reductions uh that would occur as a
result of this change um I also want to
point out that uh there is currently uh
we we implement this program as I've
mentioned before in conjunction with the
Department of Safety uh the Department
of Safety does uh allow under their
rules for an economic hardship waiver
already and uh last uh last full year
that we have data
2023 uh there were 62 economic hardship
time extensions uh that were provided
and 47 of these were actually used so um
we're not aware that this is a uh a huge
problem the current uh um program does
AOW 60 days um but uh uh again we're not
taking a position but if we did have to
do this we would need to revise the Sip
and that would take us probably 18
months or so with EPA um and again my
letter references language that's in uh
the current s spb
157 uh that uh I also referenced in HB
209 so I'd be happy to uh take any
questions thank you any questions from
the committee
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question
sure been doing some reading um and I'm
wondering if you can tell me when what
year we did the uh the national ambient
air quality standards for ozone when
when did that test take place in order
to um list New Hampshire and other
northeast states as uh as in the
excessive range yeah I'm not I don't
have the exact date um there's been
there the ozone standard is revised by
EPA um every five years they don't
always get to it so it generally is
between five and 10 years uh I believe
the last revision might might have been
2008 that we were in violation of but I
also also point out that um just by
virtue of the fact that we are in what's
known as the ozone transport region the
which are the states from basically the
States from U Virginia to Maine um that
designation that of being in the ozone
transport region subjects us to the
requirement for this test whether we're
in attainment or not so follow up follow
up as I read the EPA website though it
says that some areas that were once in
violation of the ozone na a Qs yes have
chosen to retain their IM programs as a
result of a maintenance plan and an
effort to continue to meet the
naqs so it sounds like it's something
that New
Hampshire um could well have
already exceeded or dropped below the
that excessive level but we're still
continuing it is that is am I reading
that correctly uh somewhat and let me
just clarify um
the uh and this is in my testimony
letter also the antib backsliding
provision of the Clean Air Act and I
you've probably heard this from me
before my analogy is uh a diet you weigh
250 you go on a diet you lose 50 pounds
you get 200 and that doesn't mean that
you can just automatically go back to uh
eating cheeseburgers again you want to
maintain your you want to maintain your
diet um and the Clean Air Act is the
same the anti-b backsliding provision of
Clean Air Act
section
110 um requires that once you reach
attainment that you maintain those
programs under a maintenance provision
with EPA um and that uh that goes for 20
years what follow up thank you this this
makes it sound like it is the choice of
the of the state um or the choice of the
state to pick Which counties that that
have that um anti-back liting or or that
concern is is that something that the
state decides and who in the state would
decide that if so we work uh the first
of all the designation as to whether
we're in attainment or non-attainment
with the standard when EPA promulgates
the standard we evaluate it we look at
our monitoring data and we determine we
determine whether we're in or out then
we make a recommendation the governor
actually makes that uh declaration to
EPA we we provide the governor with the
information and they they send a letter
to EPA saying that we designate as
whether an attainment or non-attainment
um but then the uh the antib backsliding
provision is not optional um uh I'm not
familiar with the page that you're
looking at but um uh the but what again
as I've mentioned we would negotiate
with EPA we would look at if we were
going to change the program we would
look at the changes
um and the impact those changes would
make on the emissions reduction that the
program gets now and we would have to
achieve those emissions reductions
somewhere else um in this case I don't
know we haven't done the evaluation of
what a change from two months to six
months would would make in terms of
excess emissions and so on but um uh we
we'd have to do that we' so the optional
part of it I guess if you want to refer
to it that way is is the work that we
would do with EPA to revise the the uh
standard and we would need between 12
and 18 months to do that evaluation get
it to EPA get it approved um and also
the department of safety would have to
change their rules at the same uh uh
that implement the program um I'm not
speaking on behalf of the department um
they're they're here so but uh that that
would be necessary to last quick quick
question could you provide um the
committee the the last time that the
evaluation was made and the information
provided to the governor to to make that
for designation sure designation yes um
I'd like to know just how far we are off
of or whether we have exceeded that and
and whether we don't have that issue we
are current we are currently attaining
at the federal standard um and uh have
been for for a number of years I I don't
have the dates right off the top of my
head but I can uh that's something that
we can certainly provide to the
committee and follow up thank you very
much any other questions committee
representative
enom uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you for being here today so a minute ago
you mentioned that if somebody currently
fails this test they can apply for a
hardship waiver correct extension yes
but not
everybody that has applied for it has
been granted that waiver no no what I
said was uh there
were uh 62 waivers were granted only 47
of them were actually used the in other
words 67 people applied got a waiver but
um 67 minus uh uh 62 I'm sorry uh so uh
of of that 62 that were provided only 47
actually needed additional time they or
they might have sold their vehicle or or
scrapped the vehicle or something else
but but they didn't actually use the
waiver thank you follow up follow up uh
thank you uh so can you address what
somebody would qualify and not qualify
if they app applied for a waiver uh I
don't just you know qualifications for a
waiver I believe there's an economic um
requirement again we don't administer
that it's administered by the department
of safety um but I I believe that um you
know there's a a percentage of of you
know poverty level income uh information
that's required um but I I don't I we
can get you that information or as I say
the department of safety does administer
that part if you could please yeah thank
you it' be great if you can get us that
information good thank you Mr chair do
you know how the public is is informed
about this waiver process because I can
tell you that I just last week had an
inspection found out I have a faulty
Cadillac converter $2,800 on my car and
there was nowhere in my briefing when
they gave me my 60-day that there was
any waiver process that this program was
available and to hear that only 60
people in the entire state of Applied
tells me that the public isn't aware so
do you know how that message is getting
to the public I believe that that
information is on the inspection report
but I'm not positive about that I can I
can uh and director Mar his staff might
be able to um respond to that as well
but we can certainly work with them to
get that information and I believe
there's information on uh on the website
um as as well uh we mechanics tell
people about it um or or what um I'm I'm
not I'm not positive but uh um I do I do
believe there's information that you can
apply for it on on the inspection report
any other questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you sir thank you
very much so with that I have no one
else who's uh open to testify on this
and just before I close out just to let
you know online we have two constituents
who supported and nine who opposed it so
with that I'm going to close the hearing
on HP
212 it's 12:15 a little bit behind um so
let's just say that our next hearing on
HB 649 will start at at 1:15
okay so have a great lunch we'll see you
back here at
1:15
e
e e
all right good afternoon everybody I'm
going to open up the public hearing on
House Bill
649 excuse me remove any requirement for
physical safety inspections and on board
diagnostic test for passenger vehicles
and eliminating funding for the motor
vehicle air pollution abatement fund uh
before we get started I see a lot of
pink cards
here um so uh if you are here to sign in
for or against the bill please use the
blue sheets if you do want to speak uh
for the bill who against the bill I need
you to fill out one of these pink cards
please keep in mind that if you've heard
your points being brought up or brought
up already it's okay to wave off we
don't need to hear the same points over
and over and over that being said
welcome again to
Transportation uh chair recognizes
representative Granger the prime sponsor
and Jeremy Olen to uh to introduce
it thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee so the premise of this bill is
that we should not have vehicle
emissions or safety inspections anymore
I consider them a scam very plain and
simple I think that the vehicle safety
inspections are scamed they're mostly
used as a way to get money from our
citizens and give them to uh some
mechanics who are perhaps less honest
there are very honest mechanics out
there and then there's less honest
mechanics but some there's a lot of
victims of dishonest mechanics who use
the inspections as a front in order to
extract money from unsuspecting
customers so the way we this sort of
bill has been brought up in the past
however it usually was done in a way
where they added a line to the rsas that
says something along the lines of
passenger vehicles are are exempt from
inspection c s as a general rule I try
to repeal if if I want to fix a problem
with law I would prefer repealing
something rather than adding additional
language um because it makes things nice
and clean so that is what we attempted
to do with this bill we tried to repeal
any language that authorize the
existence of inspections and do it in a
way that's nice and tidy and clean up
any Loose Ends um Jeremy Olson who was
next to me uh did a lot of the research
for the bill and wrote A lot of it he uh
was the former research director for the
New Hampshire Liberty Alliance so he's
reviewed thousands of bills and uh so he
helped me out with this one quite a bit
and so it was a team effort and that's
why he's introducing it with me all
right good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen of the committee as the
representative said um my name is Jeremy
Olson and um I'm from Manchester w 11
and um I helped write this bill and um
I've worked I've um worked on this type
of stuff since 2007 I've worked with the
New Hampshire Liberty Alliance reviewing
a multitude of bills on different topics
I've worked with um a group called
Americans of prosperity and I served on
the board of an organization called
citizens of Criminal Justice Reform we
in particular tackled bills concerning
problems in the prison system problems
of how offenders are treated after they
get out of prison and so on so I've been
working on legislation quite a while
here so as the topic of this bill um
simply put car inspections do not
increase Motor Vehicle Safety at this
point only 11 out of 50 states still
have these types of safety inspections
only 11 states do these on an annual
basis
several States including New Jersey and
Texas have eliminated them in the past
decade they impose an owner financial
burden on motorists not only the flat 40
to $50 fee which is basically a
regressive tax on all of our citizens
but then the potential for having to
deal with a mechanic who tells you you
need two three $5,000 worth of repairs
on your car um hundreds of people have
stories of being ripped off by un
unscrupulous mechanics of having their
car essentially held hostage
some of these people are here to testify
today um last year I was at a hearing
for a much more watered down bill and I
remember both representative Sellers and
Coker had testified that they have many
people the constituents that had called
them about problems with inspections
there are a multitude of people out
there that have problems dealing with
the inspection system and so that's why
I think it needs to go the law is
massively unpopular and repealing it is
very popular as of noon 167 people had
filled out the online submission form in
support of the bill and only 55 had
filled it out opposed that's a 3 to1
ratio of people coming out in favor
versus opposed to this bill one of the
biggest problems the inspection
requirement has no due process there's
no certain way to get a second opinion a
lot of mechanics will not look at your
car if they know it's already been
plugged in by a different mechanic
because they don't want to be accused of
people Forum Shopping and there's no
actual legal appeals process through the
DMV to get a second opinion or to have a
court review the thing and override the
mechanic
there's a complaint line r by the
dealership Association virtually nobody
knows about it we heard testimony at a
bill earlier that there's like a
hardship waiver if people need a longer
delay there's 1.4 million people in the
state only 67 people I believe applied
for the hardship W so clearly people
don't know about that either so in my
opinion it's time for these safety
inspections to go um some some of the
testimony that's been submitted um
through the electronic form and I can
also email this out to every I'm just
going to go with this real briefly a um
a former New Hampshire police officer
who worked for the State Police for 35
years and he worked on the inspection
system within the state police he said
that in the 35 years that he's worked on
inspections that in his professional
career thousands of forensic vehicle
inspections have revealed no more than
four vehicles which revealed component
failure and these were all registered in
state mandating safety inspections and
he went on for seven pages with tons of
facts and statistics I'll email that out
to everybody and it's in the electronic
submission form so I won't read all that
in today but that's yes if you guys know
him so there's a lot of people who' have
been on this committee for a while it's
Brian chase you might have heard him
testifying bills in the past he used to
run the emissions in the safety
inspection program in New Hampshire yep
so yeah we have plenty of stats and
stuff like that um one thing I wanted to
go very briefly the bill is rather long
the way it's written and the way that OS
drafted is is a little bit unintuitive
if um people want to look at the bill
and if you turn to page three line
22 that's where the actual repeals begin
they put the Amendments on the top and
the repeals on the bottom so if you look
at the bill um starting with line 27 it
repeals RSA 2661 which is what
authorizes the inspections it then goes
through on the next few lines and it
repeals a bunch of details concerning
things like fees spare tires and stuff
like that it repeals to
2668 what's important here that's very
important to understand this bill leaves
in the Statue all of the equipment of
vehicles's requirements it just gets rid
of the preemptive inspection and the
requirement to have an inspection
sticker so our police can still enforce
equipment of vehicles problems they can
pull people over they can ticket them
for problems um there's like under one
of the other rsas is a negligent driving
statue if somebody's driving down the
street with no headlights at the middle
of the night can be pulled over for that
so this will not getting rid of the
inspections will not make our roads
anymore unsafe because we still have all
the requirements that people have safe
Vehicles what it does do is it prevents
mechanics of being able to fail your
vehicle because there's a spot of
surface rust that doesn't mean anything
or any other problems like that so then
um that goes on through um the end of
the
bill back on the first page what it's
doing there is it's repealing different
bits and pieces of uh RSA
125s which is a um do you remember what
the name of the fund is air fund the air
pollution the vehicle air pollution
abatement fund yes so one of the things
the bill does is it repeals the funding
for that fund but it leaves the fund
intact so we made sure the the purpose
of that was I wanted to leave the
committee and the committee that's going
to be receiving this bill after this a
lot of leeway to decide exactly what
they want to do with that fund because
there's already money in that fund and
we don't want to get rid of a fund that
has money in it that doesn't make a lot
of sense we do have amendments that
we're prepared to offer to finance as to
ways to get rid of that which would
eliminate the fiscal note on this bill
um however I I figured that this
committee probably wouldn't want to deal
with that and leave it you since it's
going to a second committee anyway um
just know that we do have amendments on
the ready to help them to if if they
want to keep that fund around or if they
don't up to them yep and finally it
makes a change to RSA
358-a 2 this is on page two at line at
line four through line 21 and what this
is doing is it currently allows a
customer to request that a dealer
perform a safety in inspection of a
vehicle potentially at the customer own
expense if they believe the vehicle they
wish to buy is unsafe the amendment here
simply removes reference to inspection
stickers and update some of the RSA
numbers and then it replaces the word
required with requested later on that's
just so that people still have that that
privilege to ask a dealer if they think
the car is unsafe they can have them
inspect it but again we moving um
references to like inspection inspection
sticker all throughout the statue so
that's my explanation of how the bill
was written and um just a couple stories
I want to tell the committee about my
own um knowledge of how these
inspections go so I bought a car from a
dealer in Manchester autoare Honda and
the car looked like it was in great
condition they put an inspection sticker
on it two weeks after I bought the car
so I sort of have the opposite problem
two weeks after I bought the car the
entire exhaust system split off right
behind the cat a converter this car had
a brand new inspection sticker on it so
I looked up the laws I looked up the
rules I went back to them and I talked
to him and I told them very clearly I
know the law says they put a sticker on
there I had an independent mechanic look
at it and put it in writing that that
was about two years worth of rust
through the exhaust system not two weeks
wor the rust and so they went and fixed
the whole thing and no expense to myself
and then put a fresh inspection sticker
on there they were also aware that they
were supposed to put a sticker on in the
following year because I had bought the
car less than 16 months the next date
that the inspection stickers do so these
guys are basically putting a sticker on
the car without truly doing an
inspection and they didn't even know the
law about what the time delays are for
the stickers I know somebody else that
had a problem with a check engine like
he can't be here today so I was just
going to bring this in up briefly he had
a Volkswagen TDI check engine light
comes on for an environmental problem
environmental sensor problem on the car
he spend thousands of dollars trying to
fix this car there was absolutely
nothing wrong with it other than this
light was coming on he placed like an
oxygen sensor they worked on the wiring
they did some stuff with the computer he
finally ended up selling this perfectly
functioning car out of state I think to
somebody in Connecticut because he could
not get this car to be Road worthy in
New Hampshire according to the laws he
spent more money on this car than like
what the insurance company would
consider a total value for the car and
you'll hear more stories from other
people here today this is the kind of
stuff people have to deal with you got
the the so-called lick it and stick it
places that'll put a sticker on there
and it didn't actually pass you got the
people that do the exact opposite where
they won't pass the car because they're
trying to buil money out of people and
they know people are ignorant about cars
so um that's everything I have to say
about this bill the inspection system as
my friend here said it's a scam we need
to get rid of it it doesn't make people
safer we have statistics on that we have
stories about other people's problems um
it's I have to say and I'd be more than
happy to take
questions thank you very much any
questions from the committee
representative St Clair thank you Mr
chair thank you could you elaborate on
the comment you made about if people
fail it one
shop and they want to go to another
place because they disagree with what
they were failed for what what happens
so what you what you imply it happens
thank you for that question
representative so what I've heard
through other people and from mechanics
is when the car is plugged into the
computer system to be inspected when
they plug in for the OBD it creates a
record in State's database that the car
is being inspected and then if it fails
it's going to go in there other
mechanics are and other mechanics can
see this if you bring your car to that
station so if you go to a different
station they can look up the fact that
your car has been failed somewhere else
because the state can come down on
mechanics that look like they're
fraudulently giving out stickers
mechanics are very very hesitant to take
on somebody's car if it failed a couple
days earlier at another station because
they might get audited they might have
the state police show up and look at how
they're running their business there
because they basically people might be
doing like a Forum Shopping type thing
where they're just looking for somebody
that's going to pass a car so that I've
heard from several mechanics and I know
some other people have stories about
that probably testifying today to to
expand on that it so basically if you
have if you happen to run into one of
those mechanics that uh is more likely
to fail you just so they can make a
quick Buck even if you sense that
they're lying to you which most like if
you have a lie detector you can tell
someone's lying to you if you know that
they're lying to you and you look and
you say well no there's no problem with
that at all if you take it to another
mechanic good luck getting it to pass so
they kind of they kind of Tainted your
vehicle and it can cost you a fortune to
get it fixed
thank
you any other questions from the
committee seeing none seeing none thank
you very much thank you
you I'm going to go through we have a
few Representatives also would like to
testify assuming they have other
important business to do I'll take them
up first uh chair recognizes
representative
sellers you had to leave I'll put him
aside
I'm not sure Representative Sam begins
with an F who would that
be has in support of the
bill
um good good afternoon sir thank you Mr
chair your last name my name is Sam
farington I represent Rochester Ward 4
I'm here in support of the bill uh the
prime sponsor and his I guess assistant
went into good details about the
research that has gone along with this
but it's a regressive tax not just a $40
inspection fee but also the repairs that
as we know go into thousands and
thousands of dollars for maybe a scratch
or a crack on your bumper or some Rust
it's it's it's a regressive tax and it's
a tax on low-income people on young
people and for the sake of our economy
for personal Liberty we need to get rid
of this it is inefficient it's
unnecessary and we should follow a suit
as the other states have thank you thank
you sir any
questions representative St Clair real
quick you mentioned the other states you
how many other states do not have any
form of vehicle
inspection I believe uh Jeremy said 15
states have a form of this so that mean
35 roughly thank you I missed that thank
you
I thought he said 11 but who knows uh
anybody else from the committee seeing
none thank you very
much once again courteous for people's
time constraints Michael Fitzgerald the
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services not taking a position on the
bill and with uh with testimony emailed
then good afternoon again uh thank you
very much Mr chairman members of the
committee once again Mike fitzerald
assistant director of the Resources
Division uh you've heard my testimony on
the three prior bills relative to uh
altering the emissions inspection
program again we don't take a position
on this and we're not addressing the
safety portion of that um as I've
mentioned previously we operate the
emissions inspection in conjunction with
the Department of Safety uh at the same
time as the physical inspection is
conducted
um as I've told you previously the uh
emissions inspection is a requirement of
the Clean Air Act it's in our federally
uh approved State implementation plan
for uh meeting the requirements of the
Clean Air Act uh as I have testified
previously we would have to negotiate uh
with the EPA to uh determine the
emissions reductions that uh would be
lost as a result of this uh uh
elimination of the inspection and then
replace those from some other sector
however I would state that uh and again
I've stated this previously I'm
repeating
myself on all these bills the Clean Air
Act as a result of the fact that New
Hampshire is located in the ozone
transport region requires that the state
of New Hampshire uh and all the states
in the OTR have a vehicle emissions
inspection program there are some
differences between programs and so on
and we negotiated the best deal that we
could get with the EPA when we entered
into this uh uh um requirement as a
result of our non-attainment status that
um was we previously talked about in the
last hearing and um I'm highly doubtful
that we would be able to get approval
for EPA for complete elimination of the
emissions inspection program um that's
just U my opinion I'm working with them
and and um I understand that uh you know
things may be different uh uh at at this
point in time but um it's very clear the
Clean Air Act is very clear and unless
the ACT is changed or or eliminated or
this section of the ACT is changed um we
are uh required to have an A missions
inspection program and uh relative to
the motor vehical abatement fund the uh
fiscal note um I I did uh prepare part
of the fiscal note 25 cents of each
inspection goes to Dees for
administration of this program and for
administration of other motor vehicle
related programs
um uh to to reduce emissions and we
probably have uh three staff currently
uh um working on this program and other
motor vehicle related programs that
would be um eliminated with the loss of
those funds um so um with that I will
and and I also um I think it's important
to note No Matter What EPA does um I'm
sure New Hampshire would be sued the
Clean Air Act does allow for citizen
suits and those those suits um uh could
would um most likely be brought to
require the EPA to enforce the
requirement for this whether they wanted
to or not um so I think that's probably
a bigger concern um and we'd be forced
to defend ourselves against those suits
as well so um with that uh I appreciate
the Indulgence to as I have another
hearing at 1:30 upstairs and uh I'd be
happy to take any question questions and
I also have Jessica Wilcox here with me
who manages this program for us and
she'll be staying if there are any
further questions for us so I'd be happy
to address any questions if you have
them now though thank you sir I've got
one I've been doing this a long time
that's the first time I heard the
thought of being sued can you go over
what the Clean Air Act says and who can
sue the Clean Air the first time I've
heard this yeah the Clean Air and this
it's happened quite often Clean Air Act
allows for citizen suits it allows for
basically anyone who's impacted or
affected so if it would be a citizen of
New Hampshire or an organization one of
the advocacy organizations perhaps um it
does allow them to file suit and uh uh
the uh they you know if there were a
judgment under the suit then EPA would
enter into an agreement um uh a
settlement agreement whereby they would
um uh you you know acknowledge that
there's a requirement to to implement
this and that they would they would
enforce it and there would be I I assume
there'd be some time table uh and and
there already is a timetable established
for the Clean Air Act provides for
sanctions um so if we don't have a
federally approved program um they can
sanction the state and there's an
18-month clock that would be triggered
and after that they could uh uh withhold
Federal Highway funding for New
Hampshire so but the citizen suits um
would probably be the the quickest
remedy that that uh uh people who
opposed this would would use to go that
go after the EPA and us to to require us
to enforce the
program what would some of those impacts
be that they could use for lawsuits
what's what is an impact that would be
legitimate air emissions uh air
quality problems exacerbation of of um
of our equality status that those kind
of things I would think that there would
be um you know the Clean Air Act is
intended to require these emissions
reductions in order for us to achieve
Federal standards and so um it would be
a the the lawsuits would most likely be
have a health basis I would I would
anticipate okay so claims of my my
asthma's worse now oh yeah or yeah yeah
I these would not necessarily be
lawsuits particularly saying
I'm you know I have asthma or whatever
but the lawsuits would say that the
Clean Air Act is intended to reduce
emissions in order to protect citizens
and to achieve Federal air quality
standards and you're not doing that and
the Clean Air Act requires it so the
lawsuit would be to require us to meet
the requirements of the Clean Air Act
but it would probably cite Health
impacts as
a uh
reason last one for me sure I'm being
selfish
um I know recently when we've had these
bills we've been talking about
renegotiating with the Clean Air Act etc
etc but you just mentioned again the
actual loss of Highway funds yes do we
have a number yet on what that would
look like how many how much but we I've
been asking for 12 years nobody's ever
been able to tell
me I've been doing this for a long time
and I know many years ago the number for
New Hampshire was on the order of $100
million annually Plus or minus I I don't
know if there's someone from dot um U
and I don't that figure is probably 10
years old um it's very significant
though the New Hampshire New Hampshire
Highway funding um portion uh almost all
of our Interstate work and so on as it's
my understanding is done using
approximately 90% federal dollars the
Improvement of i93
Etc and those funds could be
withheld again I'm not saying the EPA
wants to do that but they could be
forced to if if there was a lawsuit and
and they were found to have not uh met
the requirements of the
ACT well I'll follow up with you later I
know time is of the essence certain it's
hard me to believe that they would take
all of our funding away if we didn't
have an inspection program but
nonetheless representative Miller thank
you Mr chairman uh thank you for coming
if I told you recently the 5-year moving
average was approximately $225 million
per year would you be surp surprised uh
I would not be surprised as I said the
figure that I cited was probably 10
years older or so um yeah that's that's
not a surprising
figure representative G thank you Mr
chair so my understanding right now is
that the uh the OBD um the onboard
diagnostic electric diagnostic is
basically the system of record for the
emissions is that correct that's correct
followup follow up so we are not
actually doing true emissions testing at
this point in time um if if that's the
case because you know something causing
an electrical malfunction which throws
you check engine light on does not
necessarily uh even most of the time
change your emissions would that be true
no the uh check engine light the onboard
diagnostics light on your vehicle only
illuminates when uh some component of
the vehicle has uh malfunction that
would cause your emissions to increase
by uh 1.5 times the federal standard
um the check engine light is only
related to
emissions no that's any other questions
from the
committee representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question if if I could just
sure it's not solely related to
emissions controls things like spark
plugs T engine timing um uh you know all
trans transmission issues and so on can
affect the can affect the engine and can
affect emissions so it's it's the OBD is
a uh thousands of components of the
vehicle are covered by OBD but those
failure of those components would result
in in an emissions
increase I'm sorry go ahead no that's
fine thank for taking my question sure
um my understanding is that um that that
test that got us to a an enhanced level
yes um is by count County I'm wondering
if there's possibility of within New
Hampshire having some counties
participate in that and some counties
don't uh the the New Hampshire
requirement is actually for the southern
four counties of of New Hampshire um
when the emissions inspection program
was implemented as I mentioned we uh
went into a negotiation with EPA they
did start the sanctions clock on us um
back in
1998 and then representative Jeb Bradley
as the uh chair of the house science
technology and energy committee
negotiated an agreement points with EPA
whereby we would Implement a uh the OBD
emissions inspection program instead of
the physical emissions testing program
there were several other pieces to that
component some reductions at at marac
station we're part of that agreement um
and uh so the we we arrived at a
compromise with EPA that they found that
they were able to approve at that time
um uh so in order for us to avoid the
more honorous uh emissions uh you know
plugin emissions testing tailpipe
testing type
program um so we're already uh doing
less than the ACT actually requires but
um that was a negotiation and and we
were able to get that through U between
representative Bradley and the
administrator of the EPA
follow up so um it was originally set up
for just the four counties is that what
you said uh under the agreement we
agreed to do Statewide because we were
doing less so that that was part of the
agreement was was to implement the
program Statewide
1998 uh the agreement was in 1998 we
actually implemented the program in the
20032 2004 time
frame represent
pyo thank you Mr chair thank you taking
my question um throughout your testimony
you mentioned attainment versus
non-attainment and I to assume that
means attainment means getting New
Hampshire out of the ozone transport
zone no no um attainment refers to our
status with regard to the federal ozone
standard so EPA sets a standard um as I
mentioned previously they review it
every five years uh and they and they
look at the science and so on and
determine what what the standard should
be
when I first started the standard was
somewhere on the order of 125 parts per
billion uh on a on a 8 Hour average
today it's 70 parts per billion but each
time they revise the standard we have to
determine whether we're meeting that
standard and that's done through
measurements around the state and when
and then we certify that we're either
meeting it which is no know as
attainment we're attaining the standard
um or we're not meeting it which is what
I refer to as non-attainment
so if we are above 70 parts per billion
on on a rolling eight hour average based
on our monitoring around the state we
have 13 monitors in various locations
around the state and um based on that
data uh and a three-year running average
of that data uh we we compare that to
the standard and determine whether we're
either attaining or non- attaining and
then there's a separate requirement for
the ozone transport region
the
questions representative Jack uh thank
you uh the Public Works committee would
agree with representative Miller that
225 is the right
number that was a great question thank
you very
much h no other question I stand
corrected seeing then thank you very
much thank you very much sir I
appreciate the
Indulgence uh next up chair recognizes
Dan Bennett from the Hampshire OU
Dealers Association
um opposed to the
bill good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee uh Dan Bennett New
Hampshire Auto Dealers Association as
you know we're a trade Association
representing the motor vehicle industry
here in New Hampshire uh and we're here
as expected opposed to HB 649 um as we
have in the past anytime the repeals the
annual vehicle safety inspection program
has been proposed um I do have handouts
uh for the committee that I'll leave
with the clerk when I'm done uh speaking
as they're filled with a great deal of
data and facts related to the program um
this program is one that benefits
consumers it supports law enforcement
and it helps keep our road safe uh we
all know that preventative maintenance
costs less than catastrophic repair
right it's why you go to the doctor
preventative maintenance that's what
this program is about it's about having
a trained expert look over your vehicle
identify problems um and get them
corrected as as soon as possible there's
some real value to the program that
you've heard us talk about before one
being safety recall information there's
a tremendous amount of safety recalls
that occur um Toyota announced on
Tacomas this morning 100,000 Tacomas in
the 24 model year uh for leaking brake
fluid they they they come out on a daily
basis when you receive an annual safety
inspection the the Gordon Derby the OBD2
program runs a check with Nitsa based on
the VIN number for that specific vehicle
whether there's an open safety data
recall and whether it's been repaired on
your exact vehicle not just in general
not just Acadia that specific vehicle so
it has tremendous value that way um in
2022 through the program when the uh
safety recall notification process
started there were 36,000 uh notices
given to citizens in 2023 there are
21,000 in 2024 there are over 10,000 and
this year already you know a month and
11 days there's already been uh 465
safety recalls handed uh and and put in
front of uh citizens so not just the
little postcard that shows up in the
mailbox this is on the vehicle
inspection report that every customer
gets when they get a safety inspection
so it's tremendously um it it's
tremendously um helpful information and
helps uh consumers get them fixed and
get that problem fixed um on the
manufacturer's dime the manufacturer
pays for it not the consumer so um
one of the things it's important to know
we talk about states that don't have
safety inspections um all of our
neighboring states have inspections uh
and they do it for a reason you've heard
me before talk about our climate our
climate is unique it's why all of our
neighbors have these programs um I heard
someone mention New Jersey scrapped
their program and they did New Jersey
scra their their program a handful of
years ago because it was a state-run
program with Union employees that cost
the state $9 million a year the New
Hampshire solution is a free market
Market it's a free market program where
a small business sets up they decide to
elect receive training become certified
reviewed by State Police and become a
safety inspector um if there's a failure
at that shop and it's identified to the
customer it's the customer's choice no
one's held hostage you have the decision
to shop it to get it you can do the
repair on your own they're allowed to
leave they they have the option to get
it repaired either with that mechanic if
they choose to or they can shop the
price or do it on their own so that's an
important component um of the program as
well the state doesn't set the rate the
the the shops do so uh vote with your
wallet if you don't like what you hear
um you know what we have seen in other
states too and I think you heard from
some folks for the standards remain the
same right so now it's on law
enforcement roadside or while traveling
to enforce that so what this this
proposal here invites is um is increase
law enforcement scrutiny
so um I did give you a bunch of facts
but here I'll give you some opinion I
don't think a whole lot of people want
increased law enforcement scrutiny right
so that's what this program would uh
provide it could just be say pulled over
for a speeding ticket law enforcement
may now be required do a little walk
around the car you know check the tires
look for lights um so increased
enforcement
um getting back to some data uh you know
the most recent study related to safety
inspection from 2023 was done by the
Journal of transportation engineering um
and it found that states uh with safety
inspections have 5.5% fewer annual
fatalities than those without so um
those states are in fact safer um it
looked at 50 states over a 44 uh year
period so pretty exhaustive
um we have an annual safety inspection
program and we still have and it's in my
handout so I'll give it to you even with
an annual safety inspection program we
still have a 14% vehicle failure rate
which means those shop those car
vehicles roll into the shop uh with a
14% failure rate if you get rid of the
program uh I can't imagine how that
number would escalate so we anticipate a
whole lot more of unsafe vehicles on the
road that can lead to accidents injuries
um fatalities so
um U Mr just to get back to what Mr
Fitzgerald said I'll conclude after that
you know emissions reductions according
to the EP a are are a piece of a pie
right we've all given our pound of Flesh
okay so if cars get a free pass and no
longer have to be emissions tested the
reductions have to come from somewhere
and what we had to ask is who's going to
make up that piece of the pie is it the
Mills the power plants the
truckers somebody's going to have to
make up for those emissions reductions
to to keep those numbers down so um
that's an end impact that could then
happen and then just importantly you all
have a copy of the bill in front of you
I'm sure and if you look at the f note
it starts at a million doll hit to the
state and then in 27 and 28 it's a $3
million every year hit to the state uh
and look to the revenue so um we'd ask
you to carefully scrutinize the fiscal
note as well so um with that being said
and I apologize for bouncing around um
but I know there are a lot of folks here
I'll give the my hand out to the clerk
and I hope that you all get a chance to
read it because uh there's some some
great content data and facts included in
that
sheet thank you question from the
committee represent name CLA
thank you Mr chair thank you you
mentioned U how many thousands of recall
stickers or not stickers but notices are
given out 34,000 I think this year or
something like that do you have the uh
numbers of how many people never
responded to those in the state too no
sir I don't sorry repres St Clair that's
not a data point that we would
track okay thank you for the questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you Mr chair next up chair recognizes
Dan good from Triple A opposed to the
bill okay okay I'll put him aside then
for
moment next up chair recogniz is Jim
Moody representative nhmro opposed to
the bill looking for three minutes good
afternoon good afternoon Mr chairman um
on behalf of Chas Bor ofar president of
New Hampshire motorcycle rights
organization
uh chair of the motorcycle safety task
force motorcycles representative on the
New Hampshire traffic and safety
commission and board member of the
motorcycle riders Foundation uh the
national voice for on on Highway
motorcyclist and on behalf of nimro uh
we are opposing uh HB 649 um her
testimony was the same that was given
approximately two weeks ago so I'm going
to skip over a lot of these uh but I do
want to highlight um uh specifically for
motorcycles uh Provisions for motorcycle
exhaust system sound testing during
during annual inspections would be
eliminated if this bill becomes law many
years ago nimro worked with state
agencies and other organizations to
bring objective sound testing to New
Hampshire to address complaints of
excessively loud motorcycles we believe
the Society of Automotive Engineers Saj
2825 measurement of exhaust sound
pressure levels of stationary onh
Highway motorcycles is an effective
procedure that provides owners
inspection stations and law enforcement
with a clear measurement of New
Hampshire registered on Highway
Motorcycle sound levels um so again a
lot of what um Dan benett just said um
eliminating uh the state inspection um
increases law enforcement um
observations and pulling over
motorcycles and testing them on the side
of the road um if it's warranted because
it it sounds exceptionally loud that's
great but at the same time it's a safety
issue every time law enforcement pulls
somebody over it's a safety issue U for
for the the motorist the motorcyclist
and the the state polies um again thank
you for your time and again we oppose HB
649 thank you very much questions from
the committee representative gon thank
you Mr chair so am I interpreting your
testimony correctly is it your testimony
that passing this would cause uh law
enforcement to profile motorcycles that
could be allowed for the sake of that um
I know there obviously nimro has
testified and I believe uh um there is
not a motorcyc well there is a
motorcycle profiling Bill U that was uh
I think passed uh last year or the year
before um again is a common occurrence U
still uh anytime you you give anybody uh
a chance to uh pull over motorcyclist um
you know law enforcement may take it um
if
a inspection uh requirement is not part
of or we do away with the inspection
requirement um that LE I think that
leaves the door open for more law
enforcement involvement with the sound
checks on
motorcycles further questions see n
thank you very much and I do have
testimon sir okay great if you can pass
that forward
all right next up chair recognizes Jason
Hennessy uh in support of the bill
representing himself looking for three
minutes and I'm going to start holding
people to what they've been requesting
all yours all right thank you Mr chair
honorable members of house
Transportation my name is Jason Hennessy
I'm a resident of am New Hampshire and I
also hold a PhD in computational
sciences and
statistics and I'm here to talk to you
about four points today uh first one is
that the the data shows that inspections
do not actually improve the safety of
either fatalities or crashes according
to multiple studies uh second most other
states have eliminated their in annual
inspections third that we can realize
some significant cost savings from
eliminating inspections and fourth that
safety inspections dis proportionately
affect the poor so first uh the question
is do inspections actually improve
safety and from all of the uh studies
that I've been able to look out look at
the best ones and the the most
comprehensive ones the answer is
universally no they do not um I'll draw
your attention to two two major studies
uh the first one is a 2015 study by the
US federal government accountability
office who did a literature review and a
study a new study themselves uh for the
Senate US Senate and what they concluded
was that studies GAO reviewed and Go's
analysis of State data examined the
effect of inspection programs on Crash
rates related to vehicle component
failure but showed no clear influence a
2018 study uh that does a differences
and differences study on New Jersey
which is actually kind of the one of the
gold standards you can get for policy
changes show that New Jersey had no
increase in fatalities or CR
es and uh and and why why is that well
if you look at the if you look at the
fatality rate even just from a hundred
years ago when we started having
inspections it was 20 it was about 24
fatalities per 100 million miles
driven uh and that was 1921 by 1970 it
was down to
4.7 and in 2022 it's down to 1.3 so cars
are getting safer we don't have as many
equipment related failures and from the
evidence that I can find only about 2%
of actual fatalities or even crashes are
a vehicle equipment related so you're
taking a small percentage of a shrinking
number and and that is why um it none of
the studies that I've been able to find
H actually can show any correlation
between fatalities and uh car
inspections second most states have
realized this
we are in a tiny minority um now I've
heard some people say oh well we have
very unique conditions because we salt
the roads uh so I got my PhD in South
Dakota and let me tell you their weather
is more intense than ours you know
you're you're encouraged to actually
pack a box uh in your car in case you
get stranded for two days because
sometimes the snow is so bad they can't
get out to you to pull you out of the
ditch so um so States like Alaska
Connecticut Iowa Montana Minnesota in
Michigan North and South Dakota and
Wyoming all have no inspections and you
would think that if that's a problem
they would have implemented
it uh 30 so as of the 70s in at in the
peak in the 70s 31 States required
annual inspections now only 11 do
so I encourage you to think about well
if they it's only gone in One Direction
why haven't they gone back if they if
they had all these issues and remember
again we are not the only cold state
that that has inspections or doesn't
have
inspections uh third we can realize some
significant cost savings for our
population and potentially the state by
eliminating
inspections so I I did a calculation
here that estimates New Hampshire
residents could save about $80 million a
year now this is counting both their
time um so you know if you assume the
average person goes for an hour and the
average wage is about 33 bucks an hour
and there's the fiscal note say had
about a million inspections a year that
works out to about uh 35 million bucks
and then the average cost of an
inspection from what I could find was
about $44 meaning that $46 million is
spent by New Hampshire residents every
year so this is an easy elimination of
costs to our to our con citizens our
constituencies
finally uh the state
I'm sure now I don't have an estimate
for this but the state has to spend
money to handle the 1 million
inspections per year there's probably
tech support there's probably people
that get called there's databases and
things like that if we get rid of these
those are things that we don't have to
do
anymore and then my last Point
eliminating uh unnecessary inspections
can improve the cost of living the
number one issue that I see I've seen
for New Hampshire in many studies is is
the housing is cost of living here it's
it's very high compared to our neighbor
and the rest of the country this is an
easy way for us to improve
that um well High income earners you
know don't bear the brunt of the
inconvenience they can take time off of
work they you know the the money is not
going to for repairs or whatever is not
going to affect them as much people on
the other end of the economic spectrum
don't have that luxury they have to take
time off of work um they have they'll
they'll have to put higher repair bills
and having a car having a car and new
Hampshire is a
necessity so if if we want to make it
more affordable here in New Hampshire we
need to get rid of
this um and you I'm sure there are many
anecdotes of cars that have been found
to have major problems but the fact is
as I mentioned earlier that cars are
safer than they were even like over
three times safer than even 50 years ago
and most people won't drive a car that
has major safety
issues elimating safety inspections
returns responsibility back to the
driver to ensure that they have a safe
car the same is done in the vast
majority of States including liberal
ones like California Minnesota as well
conservative ones like Texas and
Florida and with that I'd be happy to
take any
questions thank you sir questions from
the committee represent
P um New Hampshire currently doesn't
allow auto insurance we don't mandate it
um the states that don't have
inspections is there any correlation to
those States requiring auto insurance
thank you for your question
representative I don't have that data
off hand so I can't dance
that further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you
I did my best and even get a second
opinion uh next shair recognizes I'm
going to say Sheriff because I can't
read the name from Brentwood New
Hampshire who's opposed to the bill
ah if you can say that one more time for
the clerk please when you when you're
ready Messiah thank you
there you go I've come before this
committee today I can just get you state
your name again sorry my name is uh
Chuck mes M SS a o I'm the sheriff of
Rocky M County but I'm also a business
owner owner auto repair facility in
londondary New Hampshire called
londondary BP uh I came today and two
different versions but after listen to
some of this testimony uh when it comes
to law enforcement we hold our vehicles
to a higher safety protocol because of
all the traffic stops and all the work
that we do to those guys uh safety uh
safety inspection program is is an
essential in the state of New Hampshire
and there's a couple reasons why now I
listened to someone say that New Jersey
doesn't have uh inspection program well
couple months ago my son and my
daughter-in-law live in New
Jersey and my daughter-in-law with the
two babies in the back seat had a blow
up because all her tires were bald and
they live 4 and a half hours away for
from you so dad can't inspect that
vehicle so to say
that the program is not worth having is
absolutely wrong I mean I feel in my
opinion for doing inspections for over
40 years I think the average rate of an
inspection is $45 compared to my
$150 labor rate and if you do an
inspection correctly you're looking
about an hour to inspect a car to do it
to do it correctly um the average person
has no idea if their tie is a bald their
brake lines are leaking brake fluid that
could cause that accident um I had a car
come in two weeks ago and luckily it
didn't hit anybody because his baldr let
go and he landed up in the middle of the
road so I think the state has a great
program when it comes to uh the
inspection um it's safety of everyone
that lives in the state and from out of
state um our environmental our
environmental our environment is
different because of all the salt that's
on the road the cold the hot weather
there's a real effect on vehicles um in
my personal opinion uh the emissions
program is a great program because not
only does it help our um environment but
when we do an inspection and the
emission report comes out there's a lot
of safety recalls that we hand to the
customer and say Hey listen you need to
get a hold of the dealer uh it's going
to save you money and and it's going to
be right for the vehicle but I'm going
to end it because I know I only got
three minutes um I oppose this bill I
think it would be a big mistake for New
Hampshire to drop the safety the safety
uh New Hampshire safety program and I
hope that you know after listening to
all the testimony today I hope that you
all agree with the people that are in
this room that it's not right to get rid
of this program thank you very much
thank you sir I take any questions if
there are any are there any questions
seeing n sorry to stop
you uh next CH recognizes looks like
Jeffrey
kelman representing himself in support
of the bill two minutes looking for
welcome good afternoon to the members of
the committee thank you for your time uh
my name is Jeffrey kelman I live in
Bedford New Hampshire uh so I just
wanted to and I only have a couple
minutes I'll keep this in pretty short
because it looks like there's a lot of
people speaking on this today uh I just
wanted to mention that in my own
personal experience I've seen a uh a lot
of a highly subjective enforcement of uh
seemingly trivial thing sometimes uh so
I happen to be fairly OCD taking care of
my car uh in you know every possible
sense I changed out windshield wipers at
one time a mere days before going to
have an inspection knowing that was one
of many of the uh items on the list to
uh inspect if it could be streaking or
if there's any of these other aspects
that is something that could fail you so
uh anticipating this changed it out and
took it to an inspection spot uh and
they decided to say that your windshield
wipers are streaking well uh these were
brand new you know Bosch top of the line
you know just installed uh there's no
way that that could be streaking um but
this goes back to uh one the sub
subjective nature and then also the doe
due process component you know I say
they're not streaking if the individual
says they are I can say all right well
let's look at them all right so he
starts moving them I say you know I've
got 2020 Vision I'm looking at this
right here uh you know there's there's
no streaking but nevertheless they they
say there is and and there you can get a
fail off of measures as simple as this
uh this is obviously very you know small
anecdote but you know taking that across
hundreds of thousands of people across
the state uh and and even on something
as simple as that we've heard from
another individual that uh the the the
cost could amount to the you know tens
of millions uh both in terms of time and
and the actual physical cost so uh I I
have to imagine that that's something if
we could avoid that would be uh
beneficial for the residents of New
Hampshire
um and so I don't think I mentioned
explicitly I am supporting them the bill
as a as a result of that thank you thank
you very much
much and I would take questions if there
were any any questions from the
committee seeing none
thanks all
right next up chair recognizes
representative sellers did he leave
again nope there he is the hiding in the
back room
good afternoon committee repres
representative W chairman Walsh thank
you for the time I'm representative John
cers Bristol Bridgewater graft and 10 I
uh of course I'm supporting this bill um
I just had my inspection today well
yesterday uh last week but I had to go
back in for
repairs over $1,000 doll for something I
could have actually done if the weather
was warmer I don't have an indoor garage
but it was all mechanical I could have I
could have easily done if the weather
was warmer but it wasn't so I had to
actually go ahead and pay the man and
pay the bill you know thankfully I have
the money but there are a lot of people
out there that don't and that's what
this bill hits as well it does really
hit the poor in the elderly a lot of us
elderly people only have the Social
Security or maybe a pension that's it so
and they have to go go in and for that
stick once a year and you you are kind
of at the mercy it's not like you're
standing by the mechanic as they're
inspecting the vehicle it's in the
garage you're in the waiting room they
come back in so oh you need this or that
and they might show you they might not
show you but you're at the mercy of what
they're saying I mean even for a simple
wiper
blade I've seen them go 2030 $40 just
for a single blade I mean it's quite a
bit of
money um so as I brought up about the
cost for the poor and the Elder it
really is an issue if you really want to
help them out this program has to go and
again I heard also as well it will be a
savings a cost savings to the
state I look at uh inspections and I
might have said it last year when I was
on this committee that um it's only a
moment in
time it's good for that one moment as
soon as I drive out that door something
could happen and if I'm that poor or
something I might not fix it for another
six seven months you know but something
truly could Happ happen as soon as I
walk out that door or drive out that
door with the vehicle so it is one
snapshot in
time couple other things that we talked
about on this committee before is you
know so much pitting on brakes 50% it's
subjective are you going to count how
many pits around the brake and say oh
that the brake is already half used how
about the rust you're saying okay it can
only have so much rust or so many you
know so partt of an inch or this or that
and it's like it's somewhat sued so you
know that's the problem with the
inspections everything is not you know
precise it's it's what the mechanic says
yeah it is uh gone past that
point
um the last thing I suppose I want to
say is New Hampshire we're very unique
in New England and we could really be a
beacon until New England I mean showing
people that we are different and that
this is time that we have to change it's
it's we just have to do it and not only
that this is last thing is this is a
mandate you're mandating the people you
have to get an inspection this is not
Liberty or Freedom this is a mandate so
I'll take any questions if I can answer
any any questions from I knew child
represent of St
Clair thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative s
um you mentioned that you just had your
vehicle inspected cost $1,000 you could
have done this in the warm weather
yourself this begs the question would
your vehicle have been safe to continue
to the warm weather uh had you not had
to do this now yeah thanks for the
question and I say yes because I they
actually did show me I need part of my
frame had to be welded it had probably
three or four quarter size holes in them
so it needed to be welded so they put on
a piece of Steel all right I can do that
ball joints I only drove my vehicle
about 10,000 miles so probably about
3,000 were coming here to the state
house but my point is I only drove
10,000 miles so from last year when I
had it inspected so to wait a few more
months for ball joints I probably could
have easily done
that thank you for the questions seeing
that thank you very much thank you for
good to see you by the way yeah we do
miss you
uh next day next up J
recognizes oh you're going to you're
going to hate me uh in support of the
bill Derek verbage how do I
do well come on up and tell me how we
did yeah it's uh I'd prefer to pronounce
it
veruki so um my name is Derek Fugi um I
uh came to speak and uh support of this
bill I'm a commercial delivery driver
and I spend a lot of time dealing with
vehicles and um uh making sure that
they're safe to drive it's part of my
job um one of the excuses I've had uh
issues with in my work is employers will
claim that since a vehicle has safely
passed
inspection uh it would be an issue for
me to ground it according to Department
of Transportation policy for not having
working parking brakes but uh I I can't
can't imagine I haven't really been able
to find private inspectors that could uh
possibly do the same
thing so I I just wonder how uh I've had
a lot of experience with very subjective
uh inspection uh policies and I don't
understand uh why um people uh who don't
have a lot of money private individuals
have to get their vehicles inspected to
a higher standard than um corporations
all right thank you for that any
questions from the committee see none
you're all set thank
you uh next up chair recognizes Mary
Smith representing herself in support of
the bill looking for a couple of
minutes you'll tell me if I'm wrong in a
minute no you're just right uh Mr chair
thank you chair members of the committee
my name is Mary Smith I'm a resident of
Manchester New Hampshire and I'm here to
talk in support of this bill this isn't
the first time I've talked in support of
this bill or its various
iterations in the past by enums this
bill keeps coming up because people keep
wanting it and I keep wanting it and so
in order to keep my testimony novel some
of the things that I want to bring to
you is that driving is the most
dangerous activity we engage in on a
daily basis for most of us it's going to
be the most dangerous thing we do and we
live in a state where the motto is Live
Free or Die I don't think that the level
of intrusion into people's lives that
you've already heard about in the
testimony today is emblematic of that
motto Live Free or Die and another thing
I'd like to note given my in uh my
experience of testifying for this bill
and similar bills over the pums is that
so far not always but almost everyone
you've heard in opposition to this bill
so far has had a direct financial
interest relating to the bill where they
are directly
profiting by this system's continued
existence I mean I have my own personal
experience of having a wheel bearing
that I replaced myself after it was
reason it was caused to deny inspection
I looked at the wheel bearing I took it
apart it was perfectly good there was no
pitting it was it was beautiful but I
had to go through all of the effort
myself because where I got the
inspection they wanted to do the work
for something that wasn't an issue and
wow I they the amount they asked um for
me to pay them to do the work for
something that wasn't an issue was
incredible so I said no I'll handle it
myself um another thing I wanted to
mention is that you know this also
usually comes up about the now maybe 225
million that could be withheld
okay that's a big threat that uh we
didn't really get more detail about okay
we weren't told and as far as I don't
know how is this handled with all of the
other states the 35 or 39 depending on
if we're talking about emissions or in
other inspections or exactly how they
handle it that don't um comply with this
sort of onerous regulation that we have
on uh individual in New Hampshire are do
those States is all that money withheld
for them like if they have sips that
then turn into uh Federal uh Improvement
plans because of possible hypothetical
lawsuits brought by uh citizens um what
happens in those states do they lose
that money we didn't get an answer
nobody told us answers on
that the last thing that I want to
mention uh was that heard New Hampshire
doesn't require auto insurance that's
actually not true it doesn't require
auto insurance unless you uh have been
in an auto accident there are cases
where you will be required by law and
you can look at the statute yourself to
have insurance for a certain amount of
time I forgot what the forms called you
can look it up on the DMV website
um yeah uh
I guess I'll just end
on on that I've heard you know the
failure rate that we heard today was 14%
you know 14% you'd expect blood in the
streets I've heard higher I've heard
around 20% in the past and we didn't
have blood in the street then either so
it's this is
ridiculous thank you very much any
questions from anybody on the
committee
repres thank thank you Mr chair thank
you um you mentioned your Baron so your
inspection was not given be you didn't
get the sticker because of the bad
bearing you fixed the bearing did you
bring it back to the same station to get
your
sticker no I didn't what I did was an
option that is unavailable to most of
the low-income residents of New
Hampshire which is I got my vehicle
transferred ownership to a trust in
Montana where they don't require
inspections so this is not going to be
an option for the lowincome residents of
New Hampshire okay thank
you any other questions seeing none
thank you very much thank
you I've never seen this before let's
see if it's true next up chair
recognizes James Parker in support of
the bill who was looking for 45 seconds
okay I will be brief uh I own multiple
vehicles that I would register if I
weren't afraid of uh them failing
inspection and these are occasional use
Vehicles two of them are work trucks uh
that are of limited use on a private
property and one of them is a family
heirloom so that's
all thank you very much sir
uh next up chair recognizes Steve zck uh
in support of the bill representing
himself all right I'll try to keep this
quick uh this is it I can if you get me
going on this I can start ranting for
hours so I'll try to keep it quick and I
can stop you too all
right uh my name is Steve manic I live
in West Manchester in w 11 and
um basically I think that the entire New
Hampshire inspection sticker is nothing
but a complete scam at this
point uh and I say that as somebody who
works on their own vehicles uh I'm a
automotive hobbyist at one point I
worked at an auto dealership um I fix uh
cars for friends and family on the side
um and I've done everything from
rebuilding a transmission to uh or
rebuilding an engine and major
suspension work uh welding you name it
I've probably done it um it's you know
but it's a side hobby for me um and uh
there's a few problems with the uh
inspection uh the inspection system in
New Hampshire um and a lot of it is the
rules are very are often vague or
they're subject to
interpretation um and
sometimes the uh shops get creative with
their uh interpretation there's no
consistency between inspection stations
um one of the frequent questions you'll
see asked online is hey where should I
go get my inspection sticker done um and
people start answering and the truth of
the matter is
if the system was actually Fair it
wouldn't matter but there's no
consistency and not only is there not
consistency uh between stations but
there's not even consistency between the
same mechanic or the different mechanics
within the same station um when I worked
for a car dealership the service
director said oh when you bring your car
and have you know Bob look at it he's a
lot more lenient than the rest of them
um but the rules are the the rules
should be the rules and not subject to
sub uh subjective interpretation uh and
as people have already brought up
there's no appeal
process um the other thing is uh I think
it's time to just get rid of the program
alog together because New Hampshire's
legislative attempts at correcting or
fixing this program have basically
failed uh in 2018 the governor signed
House Bill
1517 uh which would uh basically codify
uh the rules on Rust and it's in the
rsas now and um I see people get jammed
up on Rust problems that would not
violate that law um but because of
subjective
interpretation um that they get jammed
up uh and one side note to back up uh
representative sellers um the whole
expires on your birthday thing is really
annoying if you uh were born in the
winter and you do need to make your own
repairs I yeah and you know if if it was
good for a whole year and you could do
it when it was warm out I think more
people would be okay with it
um uh and one thing that was brought up
is that um New Hampshire's inspection
sticker system is a uh free market
solution and I disagree because if this
was truly a free market solution to a
problem in the states that don't require
annual inspection the insurance
companies sure would mandate it but the
insurance companies don't require people
in states without um uh inspection to
get get a inspection
done um and also I think that the fiscal
note on this bill is incomplete and I
think there's a lot of missing Revenue
that's unknown uh that would probably
come to New Hampshire if uh this program
was abolished and a lot of it is people
are afraid to register their cars in uh
New Hampshire because of the uh
inspection regulations so people
register their cars and family names and
stuff uh out of state so they don't have
to deal with it um I grew up in the
other thing is I grew up in
Massachusetts and they have inspection
stickers too and I never had a problem
down there um when if you uh needed an
inspection sticker there's plenty of
shops that they only do inspection
stickers on Saturday you just show up
you wait in line and they're they would
have you in and out in like 10 minutes
I've gotten inspection stickers with
without uh even uh getting out of the
car uh they come up like a NASCAR pck
stop and they jack up the car check the
suspension real quick turn on your
lights Hunker horn do the OBD test all
right you're good um and here you need
an appointment and they want you to drop
the whole car off for a whole day and uh
you know it takes over an hour and uh it
it it's it's majorly inconvenient when
you don't have a problem with the
inspections um and I've always driven
older cars so it's it's every year it's
something that I'm not expecting them to
give you a hassle about and they you
know and sometimes they do um but I uh
at one point I finally bought a new
vehicle or at least it was certified
pre-owned one-year-old vehicle and had
quite a bit of miles on it um and I
bought it from the company I was working
for and I was like all when when you
know a couple months later because it's
my birthday I got to go get my
inspection sticker I'm like all right
cool finally I have a brand new car what
could they possibly fail me on I'm
finally I don't have to deal with this
headache well surprise surprise I get a
phone call from the service adviser and
he goes Steve got a problem uh you're
you're going to need new front brakes uh
to pass
inspection and when I bought the car
they told me it had new brakes all the
way around so I said well if I need uh I
was told I had new front BR new brakes
all the way around when I bought it I I
got to stop you for a second only
because I remember the story okay so if
I remember the story from a bill a
couple of years ago I think if you can
shorten it up and talk about sure but I
mean long story short uh I didn't need
do breaks uh and I when I thought when I
pushed back they they you know they gave
me the sticker um and uh I just wonder
if they pulled that tried to pull that
stunt on me and they know I work on my
own stuff uh what are they pulling your
average Grandma when she comes in for an
inspection sticker
uh and that's about
it thank you sir thank you any questions
from the
committee seeing none thank thanks very
much your point
taken um next
up I've actually got two representatives
from State Police are they independent
testimony
um okay so they're completely separate
all right um uh next up chair recognizes
uh Kyle huton the Hampshire State Police
opposed to the bill looking for 10
minutes good afternoon I will keep it as
briefly as I can I'm Carl hon I'm with
the New Hampshire uh State Police uh
Troop
G in opposition to The Spill a couple of
things that have been brought up already
uh which I will um reinforce um the
average citizen uh average car owner
here in New Hampshire doesn't have the
requisite knowledge to determine whether
or not uh the vehicle is safe in most
instances maybe not so much as looking
at the tires but Brak suspension exhaust
and things like that uh there is an
appeal process uh through trip G if you
have an issue with an inspection that
was done um we do get complaints from
time to time
the other aspect of this is that
eliminating this particular U program
would force law enforcement roadside to
basically determine whether a vehicle
was safe for operation or
not most of law enforcement has not been
properly trained or certified to
determine that especially on a roadside
uh
inspection one of the other things that
has not been mentioned in here which I
will bring up it's a more of a consumer
protection issue than anything else
every time a vehicle is inspected the
mileage is tracked so if I've got a
vehicle that's got 200,000 miles on it
um if I'm not honest I could roll the
speedometer back 100,000 miles and try
to sell it as a vehicle with 100,000
miles on it the system that we have in
place now would actually catch that so
if I got an inspected last year it had
220,000 mil on it I sell it it gets
inspected again in the state and it only
has 120,000 Mi on it um there would be a
trigger that would notify us that hey
there's a that tampering um with the
odometer which is certainly a consumer
protection
issue
um what mechanism would they bear in
place if we found a vehicle that was
unsafe roadside
um everything else I think is has been
um said here
um and the the sheriff also talked about
um the consumer not being um properly
trained um to recognize whether or not a
vehicle is is safe for operation thank
you and I'll answer any questions that I
can thank you sir question ribson of
gon thank you uh Mr chair thank you
Sergeant so you can now police police
officers and state troopers right now
can pull somebody over for observing
while driving an unsafe act or an unsafe
piece of equipment is that correct sir
yes follow up follow so is it your
testimony that you would have to train
your police to go on fishing expeditions
to inspect vehicles on the side of the
road if there is not something that's
evidently
unsafe no uh what I meant was that if
somebody stopped a vehicle for um speed
or whatever if
they hold on one second where where did
the fishing Expedition thing come from
pardon me chair uh Mr chair I'll
rephrase it would it then be your
testimony that police would have to
inspect a vehicle more further than what
they observed for a routine traffic stop
on the site of a stop uh no um part of
that would be um if they for example sto
a vehicle for speeding if they noticed
something that was unsafe they then
would have to take further action and
they would have to be trained on
recognizing whether or not something was
unsafe or
not does that make sense to you
sir yes sir I guess it doesn't make
sense because they do that now but thank
you any other questions represent
pararo thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so your excuse me
your major point today is uh the
officers aren't trained on doing um
field inspections during stops are you
indicating that there is out there some
sort of training program for the
officers in existence
or there certainly could be and I
believe uh the camp is going to speak to
that Point sorry was I
correct
training I believe he's going to be
speaking shortly if you want to hold
that question very well thank you thank
you thank you Mr chairman thank you H I
have another one go ahead thank you Mr
chairman I think you for taking my
question um I live and work in New
Hampshire only if I were to register my
car out of state would that be lawful
and if not what would the penalty
be thank you for the question yes that
is not uh legal um there there was a
requirement that if you're a resident in
the Hampshire uh you need to register
your vehicle here um depending on um I
believe it's a $62 uh fine for
that any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank
you while we're in the
mood next up chair recogniz
is Matt and moui are representing the
New Hampshire State Police opposed to
the bill for a couple of minutes and I
believe a few questions
welcome thank you Mr chair thank you
committee members my name is MD mitui I
represent the New Hampshire State Police
uh in opposition to this
bill uh this bill would um have a great
impact on the division of State Police
and all of law enforcement in New
Hampshire this bill would require
additional training that training would
have to start at the Academy it would
continue to field training uh and then
additional inservice training
uh it would increase responsibility for
our Troopers and law enforcement who are
already stretched thin and being asked
to do more with less resources State
Police has primary Patrol
responsibilities in 68 towns and
unincorporated areas and secondary
Patrol responsibilities in another 75
towns in unincorporated areas that's
nearly 56% of the state and this
continues to grow as resources uh are
stretched inin and diminished amongst um
local law enforcement County Law
Enforcement and State
Police um currently we have 62
vacancies um in 2024 the New Hampshire
State Police had over 170,000 calls for
service and conducted over 999,000 motor
vehicle
stops the items to be inspected on a
vehicle uh include 13 primary um areas
some of these areas include um steering
and suspension brakes uh tires and
wheels um during the recent
storm that we had on um last Thursday
February 6th which was a very short
duration storm um small storm in
comparison to some of the other storms
that we have we had 50 motor vehicle
crashes uh four with personal injury 47
vehicles that were off the road and 20
disabled
vehicles um inspections would need to be
conducted each time uh delaying
responses to other motor vehicle um
motorists that are off the uh off the
road Road it would increase liability on
the state police and the state of New
Hampshire as a whole law enforcement
relies on inspection stations to ensure
that every vehicle is safe on our
roadways laws are designed to protect
our general safety and removing the
requirement for safety inspection um
physical safety inspection would do the
opposite of that so that I'd open up to
any
questions thank you sir questions repr
Tower did you have a question uh in
terms of the training thank you Mr I
actually do have a different question
that's okay I uh thank you Captain your
testimony did cover my earlier question
um my new question is you just cited uh
statistics from accidents in the latest
storm how how did those statistics
correlate to
inspections so every time we would
encounter a motorist that goes off the
road involved in a an accident we
wouldn't know what the con the cause of
that crash is it could be ball tires it
could be um brakes that would would then
fall
on law enforcement to determine what are
the contributing factors of that and if
we were to just pull a vehicle out
that's off the road and let that vehicle
on its way and that vehicle were to get
into mode vehicle crash and a
contributing factor to that was faulty
breaks that liability comes back on law
enforcement in the
state yeah quick followup yeah go ahead
Ju Just so I understand the answer
um um
that you you bring you bring it up
because of a liability aspect and the
only reason I'm asking is because of
like during an investigation of a
particular accident like wouldn't a
faulty break be revealed as the as the
cause whether or not it the car passed
inspection it could okay what I'm saying
is um roadside we don't get into um that
depth of
of Investigation I don't have the
training as
to you know if the brakes aren't working
um if a vehicle goes off the road I'm
not checking the tread on
tires I'm seeing if the vehicle is
inspected and I'm going by by that
oftentimes but if a vehicle goes off the
road during a snowstorm it may be
because the roads are slick it maybe
because the tires are bald it may be a
combination of both I fear that if we
pull that vehicle out and let that
vehicle go on its way and that vehicle
gets in a crash down the road that
results in a fatality and that a postc
crash inspection is completed and a
contributing factor is ball tires that
liability will come back on the state
gotcha okay thank
you any other questions repr
stclair thank you Mr chair thank you uh
Captain um do you often reach out to
other uh State Police and State that
don't have inspections to see if just to
hear their commentary on that you know
do they complain about it do they wish
they did or is it just something that's
not discussed very much between the
agencies it's not something that I've
had discussion with okay thank you for
questions represent thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um it was there was testimony
earlier that everybody up to that point
who testified in support of the bill had
some kind of an personal interest in
supporting the bill um I'm trying to
figure out what this personal interest
of the state police would be for
supporting this um what is your
incentive you
know I have sarcastic or you know we
have no interest um the reality is we
rely on other entities to to do their
jobs and this would be an added
responsibility on your law enforcement
throughout the state um that is already
being asked to do a lot with limited
resources um I bring up the fact that
we're covering a lot of other towns our
increased calls and service
um I don't want to say we don't have
time to do roadside inspections but we
don't have time to do roadside
inspections it's it's going to
increase in delay the time that we're on
um these motor vehicle
stops yeah go ahead thank you um when
we've asked about statistics in the past
it was really difficult to
determine the whether an accident was
caused by some some kind of a mechanical
failure that would have otherwise been
caught in an inspection uh do we have
any information on that that we could I
don't have any stati statistics on that
um typically those are done with serious
bodily injury crashes and fatality
crashes where post inspections are done
um but roadside investigation um it it
doesn't typically get into the safety of
the vehicle unless the vehicle is um
uninspected or there's something that's
obviously wrong with the vehicle that's
blatantly obvious to the to the
investigating officer thank you
representative SES thank you Mr chairman
actually that was my question I want it
to be clear if I understand your
testimony then that at the present time
here in New Hampshire we do not have an
effective system to track the the
connection
between vehicle inspection problems and
crashes not all crashes not just fatal
ones not that I'm aware of I don't know
um the contributing factors I know but I
don't know everything as far as
mechanically what's wrong with with
vehicles that are involved in crashes
thank
you representative hlin thank you Mr
chair uh thank you for taking that
questions uh so you've testimony is that
without inspection this more work is
going to fall back on the your
department the state police do you have
any estimation as to how much more
Personnel you would need to be able to
complete your duties or how much work
this is going to require for
you I don't know how much more Personnel
um but it's hard getting Personnel in
the door to begin with and it's hard to
retain the Personnel that we currently
have um
our responsibilities have
increased exponentially over the last
decade um and this would just be one
more thing that would be required of us
starting at the Academy through field
training an additional inservice
training and and liability I mean if if
we are required to do this we're going
to do it the right way um which takes
time thank you yes
sir forther
questions see thank you very much thank
you sir uh next
up and I apologize in advance in support
of the bill is it
Yakov why don't you come I can't do it
welcome my name is yovav and I support
the bill um a few years ago when I lived
in Manchester I first bought a
motorcycle and was uh need to register
it I called all the shops in town and
around outside of town only one shop
would inspect motorcycles because the
state changed the the the Mandate on
what shops had to do and uh pass and and
shops just would not uh inspect anymore
uh one shop owner told me that on
principle he would no longer um inspect
his motorcycle and neither does does do
his friends do um around where I live at
the moment there are less and less shops
who actually inspect vehicles in the
first place uh for various reason either
they fail or they just don't want to
deal with it because they can make more
money uh fixing cars rather than
inspecting them um there are no new
shops um inspecting them it's become
increasingly harder just to just to go
through the process um and a lot of
issues that come up are not really
safety related but for for people it can
it's it's a lot of money and I I know a
lot of people simply don't inspect their
vehicle because they're not going to
spend a a few thousand dollars on
something that's that is mostly just a a
look and not rather an actual safety
issue um regarding a lot of shops
actually to what it was said that shops
um use the fact that people don't know
what the what the vehicles actually need
and they do it anyway say that they need
it my father took his vehicle uh that
was a few months old not a few months
old after a few months that I got
inspected to put snow tires on it and
the shop told him that he needed an
alignment uh what turned out to be is
that the shop basically tells everybody
they need an alignment because they find
just every a a tiny fraction
deviation um to to use that as an excuse
to tell people that they actually need
to do an
alignment and that is
it thank you
sir um last
card chair recognizes director morasco
from the Department of motor vehicles in
opposition to the
bill good afternoon good afternoon Mr
chair members of the committee John
morasco director of the DMV thank you
for the opportunity to speak about this
bill um this uh position we oppose the
bill uh that opposition is in
conjunction with the New Hampshire
Department of Safety Commissioner's
Office who uh also reviewed the bill and
and um offered their thoughts on it as
well um I'm here today with uh Elizabeth
mad who's the supervisor of our
registration Bureau which which um works
with all the inspection stations
throughout the state so want to start
off by saying listening to the remarks
from Dan Bennett Sheriff msas captain
amuchi and Sergeant Huddleston I think
they rais many many great points um the
inspection program based on my view at
the DMV Works uh it's a program that
provides for an important layer of
Safety and Security for the motoring
public uh we received very few
complaints on the
program um and when we do if we do
receive a complaint we act on it
uh we talk to the state police and they
send out uh Lake Ken shap put behind me
to the left uh his automotive equipment
inspectors will go out and do an
inspection um and an audit or a trooper
will go out and do that um we've
actually since while the bill continues
to come up these types of bills uh We've
added to the vehicle inspection report
so that there's a number there that a
customer if they don't feel like the
inspection was done properly they can
call they're referred to the DMB and um
and then we communicate with the state
police to make sure that we follow
through on that particular station uh to
make sure we do have uniformity and that
uh inspections are being done fairly the
other thing is I think um we've moved
into um a technology uh age here where
um maybe if we were having this
conversation 10 years ago and it was a
one-off of well I don't feel like this
station's doing it the same way as that
one or that this inspection was fair um
I've seen firsthand and I've testified
before this committee um goni Mazda
right here in conquered uh Amanda mmer
uh the uh the owner uh invited us up
some time ago to see how inspections are
conducted there um I saw inspections
that were going on with the customer
looking through the glass to see the
inspection taking place and the video
that's produced after the fact with the
mechanic going through with each section
of the vehicle that was inspected to say
it's red uh it needs to be repaired it's
green it passes it's yellow and it needs
some attention um many in and Dan
Bennett can speak to this more than I
can but many inspection stations around
the state are using this technology to
improve transparency so between that on
the front end and Troop G and the AI on
the back end um I think we're in
probably the best place we've ever been
with making sure that the public feels
comfortable with the inspection we're
going in the right direction um the
other thing is I I want to share a
personal story um since I've been in
this position I did have the opportunity
to meet with the owner of a large
dealership here in the state who brought
me outside and showed me several Stacks
tall stacks of tires um that had been
taken off of vehicles uh when they had
come in for their yearly state
inspection and that was it for me when I
saw those tires row after row after row
and asked the question that those are
from inspections those would have still
been out there if they hadn't come in
and been caught and so visually for me
that was uh that was the Clincher um so
uh the other thing with this particular
bill is I'm not quite sure uh on the
repeal of RSA
2665 um RSA 265
2665 uh affords the director of the DMV
the opportunity um when law enforcement
writes in on a vehicle that uh law
enforcement believes is unsafe for the
roadway to take action for that I'm not
sure how that would play out if this
bill were to pass if that would impede
the administrative action that the DMV
can take in instances where to Captain
uchi's point there is something uh at
roadside that he sees doesn't think the
vehicle is fit for the road and wants to
send an administrative request in to the
DMB um and the last thing I I would say
before taking any questions is we did
complete the fiscal note on this um so
that is available for you as
well thank you sir questions from the
committee um representative
SES thank you Mr chairman I have
question for director morasco if you
would sir um and actually I have a
couple if I if you indulg me I've been
pretty quiet all afternoon so far bet
you have um I'm just G to make up for it
now well not so much anyways um
commission uh director do we have uh do
you have the DMV have any uh data Trends
in terms of with respect to complaints
in other words we've instituted some
changes legislatively to try and make uh
citizens access to to make a complaint
more easy so I'm curious to see what the
effect might have been on that if
there's any data to show thank you
representative that's a great question
uh Liz mishaw does track the complaints
that come in um Liz do you want to speak
too can we get that please we we can get
the numbers uh before the executive
session sir yes sir yep we'll get those
thank you you got
it question one more question sure thank
you did ask for
two
um we heard testimony earlier today that
uh there are fewer shops doing
inspections and I'm also particular
specifically about motorcycles so I was
curious if you track data the number of
numbers of shops that do motorcycle
inspections and car inspections and if
there's any Trend that is identifiable
for that as well we can get you that as
well representative we all of the
openings for inspection stations and
renewals every two years um go through
the DMV go through Liz and her team and
registration so we can get you the
numbers for the number of stations and
try to break down that information that
you'd like all right and I I will have
one at the very end okay thank you any
other questions representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
director um is it fair to say that um
from your position you're more worried
about the safety part of it than the
emissions part of the inspection process
process yes thank you
welcome what's up you I thought you
asked for two
no guys thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking question Mr director uh do you
know what percentage of actively
registered vehicles are inspected in New
Hampshire or can you get that
information we can get it through the
Gordon Darby system um I know I was
speaking with Liz uh and and listened to
some of the testimony prior to my my
coming up here
the 14% failure rate um and uh
approximately 1.2 million Vehicles
inspected in the state every year but we
will make sure we have that uh exact
information that's that's what we have
through Gordon
Derby thank you any of the information
that's being requested I this is a
second committee bill so I don't know
how long it'll take you to get that but
as soon as you can would be great
because I think next week we're probably
going to be looking at trying to exec
this it won't take long okay any other
questions from the committee
representative foot thank you Mr chair
thank you director do we know uh roughly
how many numbers of complaints the DMVs
receive for fraudulent
um inspections or anything like that or
is that more for the State Police side
of things we can get that sir um Li Liz
has the um supervisor mot has the
complaints that come in so we can get
you the uh the number of complaints and
the types of complaints thank you the
commit you're welcome any other
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
director I have no other pink cards but
I think I have a
question I have a question of the chair
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm I was curious enough we had
anyone from the insurance department uh
testifying apparently we do not um I
wonder if there's a methodology for us
to uh for the committee researcher who's
not here today but to have him find out
um if they have any data
correlating uh
Nationwide between insurance rates and
inspection programs um I've seen we hear
a lot about there's no correlation but
uh a quick internet search uh from on my
part found too
independent uh not a not a public agency
and not a a uh interest group but rather
uh uh well one of them was for instance
Car and Driver magazine um who said
There is a correlation and that it is
favorable that the or not favorable in
that it those states that don't have
inspections get uh have a higher rate of
insurance so I want to I want to confirm
that before I take it at face
value the answer to your question is yes
we will have the researcher or myself
will reach out to the Comm Commissioner
of Insurance for insurance commissioner
and try to get some info on that
topic any well I have no other any other
questions seeing none I'm going to close
the public Mr chair I'm sorry quick
question um did uh do we have a count of
online support and opposition did we get
that I have no idea I don't know where
Ted was
represent representative Gorski was
getting them earlier I don't I don't
track
those if you if you need it I'll find it
but that's available if you need it
but I representative Fox well I have a
note I thought uh representative Gorski
announced 167 in support and 55 opposed
is that what you had that's not what you
have what I got this morning was support
15 oppose
51 and it's and that's why I don't
usually rely on them for the public
testimony portion of it it's our hearing
I mean the disinformation is good when
we looking at the exact session and that
way the windows been closed uh so the
information is a little more uh accurate
rather than fluid so so uh everybody
else good okay I'm going to close the
public hearing on Hos Bill
649 okay so here's where we're
at we still have one more um public
hearing looks like I finally got caught
up I was a little uh little ambitious
with scheduling today so we are going to
take a five minute break because I
almost let out a blood curdling screen
because of the cramp that I've got I'm
also going to be checking with the
ranking member about
possibly uh putting our executive
session off till next week I just have
to make sure that I would I don't I
won't get in trouble uh with any early
bills etc etc so let's take uh five five
minutes
e
e e
okay welcome back folks being
316 I'm going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill 7:15 relative to
personal electric
vehicles and the chair
recognizes representative
gold the prime sponsor welcome
good afternoon all
yours oh that okay okay thank you very
much uh members of the transportation
committee for taking my uh offering of
the bill I am representative Linda gold
Hillsboro to bford New
Hampshire last session you suggested
that I should come back with a new bill
on personal electric vehicles uh this
bill with the amendment is intend ended
to classify the newer
pevs and improve education safety by
creating a safety certificate program as
now in place for ohrv and snowmobile
operators a study committee or council
is proposed to work on the details okay
this is a Hot Topic by the way around
the country and New Hampshire can be at
the Forefront dealing with this issue
there is a need to protect people on
roads rail trails and multi-use
paths as these vehicles become more
numerous these protections are both for
the people using the PS as well as those
they encounter children people with
wheelchairs Etc dealers are selling
electric motorcycles as if they were
ebikes this law would have the dealers
inform
customers about uses of pevs and require
safety training resulting in safe a
safety
certificate you may not have seen some
of the newer pevs unless you live in a
larger City or there happens to be one
on your town roads I wish I could show
you some videos that I've seen it's
amazing some of the problems that you
would see in these videos if you have
not seen them it or the PS themselves it
probably won't be long before you do see
them in the meantime the safety issues
are definitely cropping up and need to
be
addressed New Hampshire can be ahead of
the issue I believe this bill with
Amendment which you should have is a
good start to address this
issue after me technical issues question
questions can be answered by Mr Dave
topam who will be speaking after
me you should have the amendment and you
should have this little testimony that I
just
gave okay thank you very much thank you
any questions from the committee
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for coming before us today um you and I
served on a uh rail trail um bill at one
point uh not too long ago and and in
there there was a question about
whether uh the federal government had
classified electric
vehicles um for the rail
trail um and it was in relation to
whether they could be used on rail
trails that had Federal funding at all
because they were classified differently
is this is this touching upon any of
that Federal classification of electric
bikes and the fact that they could not
be used on federally funded rail
Trails well I
don't not looking public so I'm going to
say no I don't quite understand some of
the part of what you're asking me but I
know this bill does uh um explain the
different classifications and what they
can do what they can't do and as I said
Mr topam could be more specific about
about that particular part of it okay I
I'll hang off for that yeah I'm sorry no
thank you very much appreciate
it repes guys thank you Mr chair thank
you representative so I just have a
quick question after reading this over a
few times I'm trying to figure out how
this plays off of things like electric
scooters and electric wheelchairs for
the handicap including those that are
cap I can't quite hear what you're
saying uh electric scooters and electric
wheelchairs for the handicap which are
capable of going off-road or may have
more power than this because of what
they're designed for how does this play
with that I still don't understand say
say it again into this microphone just I
have trouble
hearing I just couldn't hear what you
were saying let's try this I'm G to shut
yours off for a minute because sometimes
it helps
okay thank you Mr chair thank you
honorable representative can you hear
me okay so my question is and I read
through it a couple times it doesn't I
don't see any provision for uh
wheelchairs handicap scooters including
those that are made for off-road
Recreation for the handicap is it the
intent of this bill that those would be
included in
this well we do include uh the scooters
and the uh other other things is that
what you
mean there's a separate law that exists
that covers that okay thank
you any other questions representative
hlin thank you Mr chair uh thank you
representative um my question concerns
it says that in the amendment it says
that operators 12 years and older have
to complete a course what about
operators Under
12 I don't know what to how to answer
you I would think that uh that would be
up to the parents at that point I don't
really know I'm not going into the uh
those details for me at this point
anyway I don't I don't
know how to answer
you I have just one myself and it it
follows up with representative Hill i i
chaired a commission a few years ago
dealing with non-typical Motor
Vehicles we stayed away from it at the
time because we were told by that the
federal government was in the process of
defining all these themselves and we
thought that if we spent any time coming
up with laws that contradicted it it
would be a waste of time have you heard
of any movement at the federal level on
coming up with definitions and
classifications for these
vehicles I have heard of nothing from
the federal government and there are
organizations all around the country
that we have been getting together with
to discuss this bill and everybody is
concerned about it and wants to have
something
done within the states obviously since
the federal government is not doing
anything thank you very much any other
questions from the committee
representative Gorski thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question um on the second page of the
bill um it states on line 23 and
24 operation of a peev over speed limit
is a violation and shall be punishable
by a fine commensurate with any motor
vehicle traveling above the speed limit
and I guess my question is is who will
enforce
that issue well I would guess it's the
same thing as with anything these days
you know uh I don't know maybe Mr Choo
might know more specifically the answer
to that question but uh you know they
they have to be caught first of all
thank
you representative pataro thank you Mr
chair thank you representative gold um
the what do the amendment change about
the Bill yes definitely there's a couple
points that the amendment is covering
people were concerned about the bill and
then when they saw the amendment they
realized that the amendment is
alleviating some of the issues that
people had
before
yeah all right seeing no other question
questions thank you very
much uh chair recognizes David topper
represent Hampshire rail trail
Coalition is in support of the bill does
have written
testimony welcome
sir good afternoon chairman waling
committee members for the record my name
is Dave topam from Salem and there a
quick background my pleasure to be with
you again I did speak on this particular
topic last year
also for those of you who don't know me
basically I have a background in
bicycling as a certified cycling
instructor and also basically as a
part-time volunteer working for DOT for
45 years I will say literally there has
been a single program safety brochure
anything that came about through DT in
the past 45 years I haven't known about
somehow rather had my fingerprint on so
basically I have some gray hair and glad
to do do what I can moving
ahead also say back in 2019 I was a
primary author of House Bill 148 which
made true ebikes I'm talking class one
two3 ebikes legal here in New Hampshire
okay we had also a legislation we put in
last year which was not that well
defined that was House Bill 1543 that's
basically what water over the dam at
this
point now we're looking at outer class
electric vehicles primarily here in this
house bill
715 it's a quick wear about my other
background I serve on multiple boards
including bike Walker Alliance of New
Hampshire which did speak to folks spoke
to you this morning from that group and
the president of the New Hampshire rail
Trails
Coalition also on the board for the
grant State rail trail and probably most
important for today's discussion where
we go from here I'm a member of the
Department of Safety Traffic Safety
commission look your folks on boy here
today so and Linda gold represent gou
just passed out something to you which
I'll refer to briefly this is nine pages
some color printing at all not to
belabor it but say this is something you
can glance at because I find one of the
key factors and talking with my friends
here in depart uh Department of
Transportation as well a key factor is
education education what it is that
we're talking about what are the
vehicles who's using them where are they
using them why are they using them so
hand in hand with that overall concept
of what's going on
here we have I have been personally
involved for the past year I won't say
how many hours but definitely at least
eight working sessions
involving about 10 States including
National organizations including the
league of American bicyclists Rails to
Trails Conservancy people for bikes
based in
argon and one of the most informative
sessions that I had recently and glad to
get the input in August I attended the
traffic safety commission meeting over
here the Theos building and a lot of
input was received then that caused me
to rethink some of my overall
perspectives that I had received from
the outside world talking to the other
organizations by clubs Regional groups
you name it again there's probably
hundreds of hours that g into that in
the past year or that I boil it down to
what I call a series of viewpoints what
do I think kind of coales the whole
thing together a couple key points I
think I just like to mention before we
get into any nitty-gritty details here I
think you all have to admit that techn
ology moves much faster than
legislation you know the advance of
these newer
devices whether they are the I call it
the outer class otic Vehicles OCS
motorcycles with pedals that can go 60
mil hour by hitting a throttle button
and being sold and used as F bikes if
you're talking about high-speed scooters
onewheel devices and even now electric
unicycles these are newer units that in
fact a lot of people don't even know
what we're talking about so the first
few pages of this handout basically just
tries to Define what they are where they
use I won't go into the details but
again class one 123 ebikes are totally
legal here in New Hampshire with the
caveat being the class three that can
contain 28 miles hour if you are
pedaling not allowed on rail
Trails so at Federal standards there was
a question I asked a little bit earlier
has not changed nationally at all that
ebikes true ebikes class one two three
are classified still as bicycles
low-speed electric
bicycles they are allowed on rail Trails
all the way through even federally
funded ones because again they are
bicycles they're not Motor Vehicles
that's the key factor they're not motor
vehicles and that's the way the law is
written currently here in New
Hampshire my problem our problems rail
trail folks are and Road users you see a
picture here on about page three about
what they call this 12,000 watt Mad Boss
bike 16 horsepower it'll do 60 mil an
hour it's being sold as if it's an ebike
even in Dairy if it is go use it it's
all an ebike no registration no
licensing no training just take it and
run so they have a problem especially
when they're on even roads I see talk
about Lane SP in vehicles on roads it
still comes down the fact that these
vehicles are all over the place again
with no license no registration they're
just out
there the guideline by the way that came
about that to set the guidelines for
ebikes came out in 2003 from the
consumer product safety commission
that's been recently revised and they're
looking at currently battery safety
safety characteristics breaking all well
and fine I've been following those
details intimately but they are not
looking at where and how these devices
are used they're not saying about they
be used on roads or not so keeping on
from there a little bit about the
definitions we talked about I'm viewing
everything and the spill views
everything that is above the one
horsepower 750 watt if you would powered
speed of 20 mil an hour which is the
limit for True ebikes class 1 two 3 they
are not powered over 20 M an
hour how ever this is not attempting to
address I call the lowend electric
recreational toys the girl has a little
Barbie Jeep in the driveway that might
go 5 or 12 miles an hour that's a
recreational toy they don't blow belong
on our roads by the transportation
system anyway so that gets a basically I
view that is local municipalities got to
control that when your neighborhood they
might be allowed on sidewalks they might
not I don't want to get into that I'm
looking at Transportation type
Vehicles so saying up front that the
bike ped community in K Julia I'm not
against these higher powered devices but
where and how they are used is the
problem they do provide opportunities
for many people maybe they can't afford
a car maybe they're handicapped we talk
about ADA Compliant folks all these
devices can be used by Ada type folks
just using that term
generically because they need Mobility
to get around and the Mobil Ada law says
basically they can use basically what
they want within normal limitations
including on rail throughs so again the
Ada folks basically got a free slate to
use what they want no question about
that whether they're electrically
powered or not
see main thing I see up front is
basically Kon courtesy whereby so many
people even motorists on the road if
they display a bit common courtesy about
handling things correctly we're a lot
better
off and keeping in fact we talk about
the speed capability of some of these
devices I think it's wa page four or so
of this handout you've got a chart that
lists a
comparison of different types of
vehicles whether they're ebikes oped
scooters all up the
motorcycles whether they're registered
or not the horsepower
range I've come to realize and I think
you will also It Isn't So Much the power
or speed that a device is capable of
it's how it is being
used we all drive cars I think everyone
in the room is driving a car it might be
able to do 120 30 miles an hour on an
open road it's totally legal if you
driving 65 M hour on Route 93 it's
totally legal if you're using it for 30
m hour a congest the urban
area just because the vehicle can go
fast doesn't mean it has to be used at
that
speed so just keep in mind I think speed
is actually more important than the
classification and power off harow of a
device now get again the idea of equity
I mention a little bit the folks who
need to get around whether they've lost
a
license like a DUI case talking with
folks Department of Safety just a little
bit ago some of these folks have no
other way to get around and if they can
use an ebike or a vehicle of some sort
to accomplish their needs missions food
whatever oh well and fine I don't see a
problem with that provided they are
following the
law again wrapping up my little quick
testimony here might be more than four
minutes at this point talking with
Department of Motor Vehicles a bit some
of these devices do not have uh VIN
numbers on ver vehicle identification
numbers becomes a little bit problematic
how you register them if you don't have
a number secondarily as I found out in
the world of effectively electric
unicycles which again little picture
over there the one wheel where you stand
to sit on that and you just go that a
lot of those folks don't own one of
these devices for three or four months
before they rotate out and they get a
different one it's like a hobby but
nonetheless I know people even in the
lights of in someone in Nash is using
one of those to get around because he us
a sa he can't walk but he can use the EU
to get around town so not a problem
might be ADA Compliant maybe hasn't gone
that route but he still use them for
transportation and not opposed to that
at all
personally and the idea is again the
education that was brought up in the
amendment basically the main point of
the amendment we have a lot of things to
discuss more than we can we the weeds
too much of this afternoon and
appreciate your time but it still comes
down the fact we talked about having a
safety education type of a program ourr
the safety certificate program you folks
probably know full well that our fishing
game has the safety program for again
ag12 you ask where that came from i z in
on that ag1 12 and up they have the
safety certificate program for children
if you would getting onto snowmobiles
and ohvs they take this online course
they get a safety certificate they're
required to carry it say yes they know
something about this device that they're
getting on not getting on there suddenly
hit the thr autle and crash because they
don't know what's going
on they do charge a minor fee for that I
think it's about $35 and it's not a
license it's basically saying you've had
training you have some
information when it getes of how that
can come about I'm fully aware the state
of New Hampshire is under very tight
budgets things are being cut back a lot
this year there's not enough money to go
around I've been working with uh groups
around the country including s Francisco
University program and they have the
skills and wherewith all to help to
develop the cost a little to no cost at
all to the state if there was a minor
seed money I'm told that folks in the
department of safety might have a little
bit of money to help kick that off get
it going but not State money so this is
not impacting state budget
if we were to develop a program the
content of the program however it
doesn't exist today in the country
anywhere I've looked high and low we do
not have a program we just go out and
grab it for ebikes especially the EU
community so what we try to do is to
call us enough I picked up the ter from
Department of Safety dispatch you
subject matter experts if you would
officials really know what they're
talking about if we can get together as
a committee or a council if so directed
with this amendment we have out that we
can meet offline and flesh out what
really makes sense what could be put
into a program to direct people to take
it to become safer operators of these
vehicles whether they're on roads Trails
or whatever they need training they need
education it doesn't exist today so
we're looking for a consensus of
opinions to move it ahead with I call
the legisla directed committee or
that we can review the idea of putting
together a safety certificate program
then steer people to it we can't tell
people to take it when it doesn't exist
plain and
simple so that's my my sped probably
over four minutes but entertain any
comments or questions at this point
thank you very much you're right it was
much more than four minutes I think I
have a question over here representative
Hill thank you Mr chairman um I have to
confess I'm confused by what you're
looking for with this legislation um
other than perhaps even just classifying
certain
things um as either motor-driven Cycles
or personal electric vehicles all kinds
of things but I also in in following up
somewhat on chairman Walsh some of this
is I believe under consideration by the
federal government as we speak although
maybe not at a snails pace here um but I
am concerned there was another bill that
we had last year not yours that was
concerning because of the motor um the
electric motor vehicles were being
suggested by some um judges for people
that had lost their license to go get
one of the electric bicycles that um
were perhaps even going as high as 60 M
hour which I think the minimum a speed
on the highway is is 45 so they would
qualify to ride on on the highways
without licenses or registrations so I
see the need I'm I'm wondering what it
is you want us to do do you want us to
create a study committee I don't see
those words here I see it in testimony
but not words so I'm I'm trying to find
out what it is you want done I might ask
ask that two parts first of all as far
as the use of vehicles are concerned
whether it's the DUI crowd whatever they
want Wheels to get around the problem we
have with somebody is on one of these
quote electric motorcycles whatever the
16 horsepower one for example reference
over here currently they are not
classified as a motor vehicle if they
were classified as a motor vehicle I'm
all in favor of that on the rsas Today a
motor vehicle including a motorcycle can
be electrically driven it doesn't it's
not excluded as a motor vehicle because
it's got a battery on it okay so if
these higher class uh Vehicles higher
speed higher power were in fact
classified as Motor Vehicles then they
would have to be registered insured
licensed operator and the law would be
there to take action on because if
you're using an unauthorized vehicle on
the road you got a problem right
okay yeah I I've got to ask a question
here are you all set yeah just in terms
of the bill itself how it's written
itself I I'm a little confused as I read
through this too it just kind of sends
you in a bunch of different directions
for example on page two line one
through five of the bill I'm not even
looking at the amendment
yet uh due to the nature of a personal
electric vehicles not having vehicle
identification numbers and frequent
change ownership a typical vehicle
registration is
Impractical instead a person operating a
personal electric vehicle must be
certified it's a skilled user by
completing the New Hampshire Department
of Motor Vehicle Safety exam what do
those two things have in common and how
do they relate to each other how can you
just because you don't have one how do
we change the whole topic and go into
something else point so address a bit I
think in the amendment first of all
again you can't take a course that
doesn't exist we think we have to admit
that
and then secondarily as far as what's
required moving
ahead we want people to be safe on the
road they should be skilled in what
they're doing and the idea is if we have
a committee to work out the Weeds on
this and fine-tune this to make it more
meaningful again I don't expect this
bill to at the least be passed the way
it's written today I'll tell you that
but if we say this is enough of a
problem that we need to get our heads
together and work out the details
through like of a study committee
whatever you wish to call if it's so
directed we can work out the details
because right now law enforcement
doesn't know what to call these things
they running around rail Trails roadways
state
parks and basically we need to get hands
or handle around it and again we can't
do it all today the weding of the
original bill and even the amendment
doesn't really cover everything and I'll
just say that even as recently as last
night the online kist the online portal
that was quite interesting how see the
account was going on that one that
basically people are saying that we need
to do
something the C is up here I think of
uh last last night was a 26 saying do
something favoring the bill in
generalities and five
against it's also interesting to note
that some of the comments came in one of
the oppositions you read the text behind
it 100% in favor of doing something but
he click the wrong button so you can't
always just go away those numbers but
any case bottom line we have more work
to do on it and that's why I'm hoping to
have this uh quote study committee
whatever you wish to call it so we can
address the issues the vehicles are here
they're driving people crazy back here
in August at the safety commission
meeting
we had three officers from the
Manchester Police Department we had
someone else from Kean we had State
Police we had DMV all say this is a
problem how can we get our hands around
it so I'm still trying to get my hands
around the whole thing and there's some
deviation yes in the text I fully agree
with you Mr W that again we need to work
on it that answers my question a little
bit but any other questions from the
committee representative hin thank you
Mr chair uh thank you for being here
today um so I'll go back to my earlier
question I posed before um whereas I
don't see anything that it has age
restriction as far as who can or cannot
use these the only age restriction comes
to if you're 12 years old according to
the amendment you have to show a safety
course but as a 10-year-old my grandson
does not have to have
any type of a safety course he can just
use any electric PV on the uh rail
Trails
correct well stting off with a 12 year
old Point that's defined in the current
stipulations for those getting the
safety certificate from fishing game for
OHV or whatever being that they're all
enough to understand rules of the road
they know left from right they know what
some of the problems are a certain level
of of recognition for hazards and they
can absorb things like rules of the road
basically come arbitary different kids
different ranges you know different
abilities ad midly but those under 12 we
I view and I think most the other folks
view as basically their children they
don't have the cognitive ability to
really sense dangers and do things so
they're under control of their parents
the parents must have some
responsibilities for their own children
but even in the fishing game again they
start there safety program 12 years old
and up okay so that's where that 12
years old came from again we're talk not
talking about trying to get the little
girl on a pink Barbie Jeep and a
driveway certified ESP basally the
parents
and representative Miller I thank you uh
and I just want to follow up on the
they're not classified as anything
currently today and we don't know what
they are can you I mean I just briefly
looked through what a moped is for
example and it's anything that goes 30
miles per hour or less doesn't it could
be any electric Moto or not y um a motor
driven cycle I believe the limit is a 5
horsepower engine so if we're talking
about uh you know a higher a larger
engine than that it would be something
else but I'm curious is is it a problem
the state police have said that it's not
we don't know what these are is it
dealers don't know what these are who is
saying we don't know what these are are
Vis the current legal structures we have
that seems like really current answer no
one knows what to call them that's why
we're trying to classify these again the
chart that we have over here if these
vehicles have the size weight power and
everything of a motor vehicle the
feeling is that they should be
classified as a motor vehicle with again
registration Insurance whatever if it's
a lightweight device and talking to the
EU at this particular point which is
about the same weight as an ebike you
know 40 50 pounds maybe 60 whatever
there cargo bikes are another category
but it case basically if a device like
the
unicycle is viewed more of a an
ebike than a motor
vehicle because of the heads of the
weights and everything a person on an EU
doesn't have a front wheel to crush if
he runs into something okay they
typically wear heavy duty body arm
regular motorcycle crash suits if you
would so basically they're usually very
aware of what's going on and they're
very prone to injury if something goes
astray and by the same token them using
these devices they mentioned a fellow in
ASA whether he's tot fully under the Ada
coverage or not people are using those
for transportation to get around and if
they want to go on a rail trail as I've
encountered folks in Salem 12 15 M an
hour on an EU that might have a maximum
capable top speed of 50 it's totally
fine if he's doing the rafield at
50 okay anybody else from the committee
see thank you very much thank
you next up chair recognizes dard Bard
New Hampshire Department of
Transportation active
transportation for
Gary
um not taking a position on the
good afternoon chairman Walsh members of
the committee my name is Jerry Bard I'm
the active Transportation engineer for
the de New Hampshire Department of
Transportation as such my job or role is
just to try to assure that the state
highways and roadways can accommodate
pedestrians and bicyclists are active
modes of transportation as as much as
practicable
um the do has no position in this
particular bill I spoke here last year
on a similar bill and the main concern
is that um electric bicycles were were
in last year's bill and it's mentioned a
little bit in this year's bill um there
exists very good laws already in the
state of New Hampshire for electric
bicycles uh the max speed for electric
bicycle class one and two pedal assist
is 20 M an hour and 28 miles an hour for
clash 3 uh they can go faster just like
a regular non ebik can go um
if you're going downhill so that's all
just didn't want to mix up or throw the
baby out with the bath bath water here
the the electric bicycles laws that
exist today already so and we encourage
those at the Department of
Transportation as a form of
transportation and with that I just
offer myself up for any questions all
right thank you very much any questions
from the committee representative Miller
yeah thank you Mr chairman in in your
opinion would the Department of
Transportation agree that these devices
particularly the two wield ones would
not be a moped or motorcycle but would
be some other thing that is not
currently classified by the
rsas
um to speak to all the different rsas
that are out there because there there's
the assist of Mobility devices for
disabled people there's off Highway
recreational vehicles and like Bill
Lambert said this morning I'm not a
lawyer I didn't get into all there say
so I can't say for
sure any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much
and we have a late
arrival not taking a position on the
bill chair recognizes director marasco
from the Department of Motor Vehicles
welcome back thank you Mr chair members
of the committee I won't take much time
at all I just wanted to as I listen to
the testimony just recognize the
representative and Dave Topham for uh
what they're trying to do here um you
know I have been part of many
conversations with Dave the office of
Highway Safety um and many others about
this issue I can tell you that in
speaking with uh dmbb directors from
throughout the country it's an issue in
every state and people are trying to
figure out the best way to to solve it
or try to solve it um to save lives
really that's what this testimony is all
about saving lives for the rider uh and
for other people that might be on the
sidewalk and a an eunic cycle comes up
behind you at 30 miles an hour um those
things are happening and so um what I
have found through anva the American
Association of Motor Vehicle
administrators there have been surveys
that have been sent out to DMVs
nationally on this issue and how they
deal with it and what you'll find is a
lot of times there's very little at the
state level most of it is handled
through town ordinance so they push it
back to the town just like noise
ordinances uh to try to deal with it but
what Dave and the representative are
trying to do with defining these
vehicles through um what's in this
packet um that's arduous and and uh
takes a lot of work um and I agree I
haven't seen the amendment to this bill
but if the amendment is to create a
committee um and to get uh subject
matter experts if you will or other uh
stakeholders around the table to talk
about what's in this packet and try to
find a solution we're happy to work with
uh with Dave and the representative and
I know that Lieutenant Storm from the
state police from Highway Safety would
be happy to do that as well so I just
wanted to offer that and um happy to
take any
questions thank you sir any questions
repr sentive
pataro thank you Mr chair thank you
director taking my question a lot of the
testimony so far in this bill has to do
with an educational component and a uh
safety certificate program are those
ready to go from the DMV or would they
have to be developed that's a great
question representative they would have
to be
developed gon thank you Mr chair Mr
director um have we have you looked at
what it would take to develop this kind
of program like what kind of workload
would we be putting on you with this sir
that's a great question Representative
no no I haven't I I I read the bill um
you know obviously online training
certificate um you know they're great
ideas that being said no I haven't had
an opportunity to really think about
that thank
you anybody
else seeing none thank you very much
thank you Mr chair and that being said
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill 7:15 FN
and just give me uh one or two moments
to decide our next
move
e
e e
all right
folks I have made a
decision uh first of all I usually do
pretty good at scheduling but it looks
like I was a pretty aggressive this week
and we're looking at
4:00 uh realistically that doesn't get
some of us out here till
six um right now we only have six bills
left to hear that's not bad we're in
pretty good shape it's only February
17th uh we do have considerably more
than that to exec but our first deadline
is March 6 for early bills to report out
that have to go to a second committee so
this is what I think we're going to do
we're going to have we're not going to
go into exec session today I'll say it
publicly I'm not open I'm not taking up
any of these we're not going into
executive session I will reschedule
these what we're going to do next week
is hear the rest of our bills we have
six more to hear and we will exec at
least the early bills maybe a few more
I'll I'll go through the schedule we're
going to take school vacation week
off and then we're going to come back in
the first week of March I think it is
March
the fourth that Tuesday to clean up
everything that hasn't been exec yet
that actually works pretty good because
I know there were a couple of bills that
people were looking at amendments a
couple of bills that people were still
trying to do a little bit more work on
we've already pushed a couple of down
the road a little bit excuse sorry for
the transportation metaphor but I think
that's a good plan and uh it doesn't
beat us up tonight and we'll make all
our deadlines so that's the rule and for
the anything for the good of the
committee next week and again I'm going
to do the schedule but but we have six
more to hear so I I'll we'll hear those
and I'd have to go through my list one
more time just to make sure I'm not
missing any early bills I know we have
at least three possibly four we will EXA
those as well next
Tuesday and then the balance of
executive session we'll have a nice long
fourth of March and clean up everything
the the committee waiting for
crossover all right any other
questions see youone thank you very much